OKAY ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING
WE'RE GONNA BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY'S
HEARING OF COURSE IS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- PORTION OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON THE
FUNDING FORMULA OTHER PROMISE
PROGRAMS A CAPITAL OUTLAY ONLINE
A COLLEGE AS WELL AS THAT BASIC
NEEDS.
OUT WE WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT
IT'S OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
OF THE WORK COURSE OF OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE EARLY JANUARY BUDGET
PROVIDE A GOOD STARTING POINT --
FOR BASIC FUNDING FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- NOT NOT A
LOT OF EXTRAS THAT WE HAD IN THE
PRIOR YEARS WE HAVE A FEW
PROGRAMS WE WANT -- TO GO OVER
THAT WE HAD -- FUNDED IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS -- SO WITH
THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER -- ONE FUNDING FORMULA IN
APARTMENTS [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
YES AND WERE INTEGRAL TO QUICK
[inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED OKAY.
THE MORNING CHAIR IN MEMBERS
MICHELLE NEW IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTINUES
TO IMPLEMENT THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
IN ADDITION TO ENROLLMENT THE
FORMULA ALLOCATES GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BASED ON
ADDITIONAL FACTORS SUCH AS THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ENROLLED.
AND SPECIFIED STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS SUCH AS THE COMPLETION
OF A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN APPROXIMATELY 70% OF
FUNDING WAS DISTRIBUTED BASED ON
TOTAL ENROLLMENT. 20% ON
ENROLLMENT OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND 10% ON STUDENT
SUCCESS METRICS.
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES SOME
REVISIONS TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN. FOR THE FORMULA.
SPECIFICALLY IT MAINTAINING TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RATES
FROM FOR THE FUNDING FORMULA
INTO.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
CAPPING YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH
FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION AT 10%.
AND CLARIFYING THAT THE
DEFINITION OF TRANSFERS SHOULD
REFLECT AN UNDUE BLOCKADED COUNT
OF STUDENTS.
THESE REVISIONS WERE PROPOSED TO
ADDRESS ISSUES REGARDING
ANOMALIES IN THE DATA FOR THE
STUDENT SUCCESS AND SUPPLEMENTAL
ALLOCATIONS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS ALSO INTENDED
TO GIVE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
ADDRESS THE FORMULAS LONG TERM.
FISCAL STABILITY AND IMPROVE THE
ACCURACY OF DATA REPORTED BY
DISTRICTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
ABORTION MINTS INCLUDING TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF POINT 55%.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR A THREE POINT
46% COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
CAN.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS AT
GROUP BROUGHT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
MOTOR COVER TWO ISSUES --
RELATED TO PORTIONS HERE FIRST
IS AN ISSUE THAT'S IN YOUR
AGENDA WHICH IS RELATED TO A
PENCIL SHORTFALL IN -- EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ANOTHER THERE ARE A
COUPLE VERY ABLE ESTIMATES OF
THE SHORTFALL BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- MAYBE A
DECISION FOR YOU -- COME MAY --
IF THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
PROPOSED TO THE BACK WHAT
SHORTFALL AT THE ME REVISION --
WILL BE WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE
WANT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND TO BACK FOR THAT.
THE PROVIDING SOME FUNDING TO
BAFFLE THAT SHORTFALL MIGHT BE --
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HELP ENSURE
THAT YOU'RE SINGLING SUPPORT FOR
THE FUNDING FORMULA AND FOR THE
CONCERNED WITH IMPROVING STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THIS IS THE
YEAR WHEN THERE ARE MORE LIMITED
PROP AND YET RESOURCES AND THAT
MIGHT NOT BE SOMETHING THAT IS --
THAT IS FEASIBLE THIS YEAR I'M
IF YOU DO -- DECIDE NOT TO BACK
FOR THE SHORTFALL IN QUESTION
WILL BE HOW THAT -- SHORTFALL IS
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE CHANCES OFFICES HAVE
INDICATED THEIR PREFERENCES TO
ASSURE COLLEGES THAT THEY WOULD
BE RECEIVING AT LEAST SEVENTY
NINETEEN PLUS COLA -- SO THAT
THERE IS SOME OF THE DISTRICT
THAT DIDN'T GET AS MUCH UNDER
THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA WOULDN'T
TAKE -- MUCH OF THE THE CARD WE
THINK THIS APPROACH -- SEEMS
REASONABLE GIVEN THAT THERE WAS
A PRETTY BIG VERY ABILITY AND
THE YEAR TO YEAR INCREASES THAT
DISTRICTS RECEIVED UNDER THE NEW
FORMULA.
I'M THE NEXT I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT THAT THE TWO PROPOSALS
RELATED TO THE NINETEEN TWENTY A
BUDGET AND AND OUR THAT'S BEEN A
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE.
I'M SO FIRST ON THE PROPOSAL TO
DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
THE DELAY THE INCREASE IN THE
STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION -- WE
DO THINK THAT IS A REASONABLE
APPROACH -- WE DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME AT THE TO ISSUES
FOR THE STATE TO WORK OUT -- WE
HAVE A THERE'S A CHART ON PAGE
SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA THAT COMES
FROM OUR ANALYSIS -- WHERE WE
WERE LOOKING AT JUST THE LAST
TEN YEARS OF -- THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY ASSOCIATE DEGREES --
AWARDED -- STATEWIDE AND AT
VARIOUS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS ARE THE DATA LOOK
SIMILAR IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
CERTIFICATES BUT WE DO SEE SOME
SIGNIFICANT VARIATION FROM YEAR
TO YEAR -- AND THERE THERE'S NOT
A CLEAR EXACT ONE ANSWER FOR WHY
THAT'S THE CASE -- WE DO THINK
THAT ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF A RELIABILITY
ACCURACY OF THE DATA ARE
IMPORTANT AND WE KNOW THAT THE
CHANCES OFFICES INDICATED
THEY'RE GONNA TAKE SEVERAL STEPS --
TO TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES I'M
IN TALKING TO SOME DISTRICTS ARE
WE DO THINK THERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL -- THERE MIGHT BE
VERY VERY XIN IN THE STATE I
EVEN IF YOU TO DEAL WITH SORT OF
THE DATA RELIABILITY ISSUES.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE DISTRICTS
GOING THROUGH SPECIFIC LOCAL
ISSUES LIKE CHANGES IN IN THE
LOCAL ECONOMY OR CHANGES THEN
FOR EXAMPLE -- THE NUMBER OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE ADMITTED
BY US YES USE IN THEIR LOCAL
AREA THAT CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
AFFECT THEIR YOUR TO YOUR
OUTCOMES -- SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT YOU -- IT CHANGE
THE THING SIX ALLOCATION SO THAT
RATHER THAN BEING DRIVEN BY ONE
YEAR'S WORTH ROCKING DATA IT'S A
THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE.
THAT WOULD ALSO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT WITH THE BASE
ALLOCATION WHICH IS DISTRIBUTED
BASED ON A THREE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE OF ENROLLMENT.
THAT WE THINK WILL HELP WITH
STABILITY FOR BOTH -- DISTRICTS
BUT ALSO FOR THE STATE AND
PROJECTING WITH A FUNDING WILL
BE IN THE FUTURE.
I'M ON THE SECOND ISSUE THAT
THERE ARE SECOND PROPOSAL THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS RELATED
TO ARE PUTTING A 10% CAP ON THE
YEAR TO YEAR GROWTH IN THE
STUDENT SUCCESS OKAY.
WE DO RECOMMEND REJECTING THAT
PROPOSAL I'M MORE CONCERNED THAT
IS IT WE APPRECIATE THE CONCERN
ABOUT CONTAINING COSTS IN THE
FORMULA BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THAT APPROACH.
IS THAT COULD APPROACH THAT
COULD REDUCE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR SOME DISTRICTS
ARE ACTUALLY MAKING NOTABLE
IMPROVEMENTS IN STUDENT OUTCOMES.
AND SO WE WOULD RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING OTHER ALTERNATIVES --
THAT WOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE
STRONG INCENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME -- CONTROLLING COSTS
AND AVOIDING SOME OF THE SORT OF
NEGATIVE INSTANCES WE MIGHT BE
CONCERNED ABOUT -- ONE
PARTICULAR -- THEIR NUMBER OF
WAYS THAT YOU COULD DO THIS THE
ONE SPECIFIC OPERA SO WE
RECOMMEND IS TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF OUTCOME BASED FUNDING THAT
COMES FROM.
THE COME FROM ANY INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT IN ANY YEAR -- SO FOR
EXAMPLE STUDENT WHO EARNED AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE -- AND THE
CERTIFICATE THE DISTRICT ONLY
GET FUNDING FOR THAT ASSOCIATE
DEGREE AND WE THINK THAT THE
APPROACH THAT -- CONTINUES TO
STILL GIVE DISTRICT INCENTIVES
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES TO IMPROVE
STUDENT SUCCESS WILL REMOVE THAT
NEGATIVE INCENTIVE TO SORT OF
TAKE STUDENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
COMPLETING ADDING AND
ENCOURAGING THEM TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL CERTIFICATES.
I WOULD THINK THAT APPROACH
WOULD WOULD REDUCE COSTS IN A
WAY THAT I STILL HAVE STRONG
INCENTIVES FOR IMPROVING STUDENT
SUCCESS MORE BROADLY.
I'M SO STOPPED THERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
CHRISTIAN LAST MINUTE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE -- I'M GONNA
BE WORKING OFF OF THIS HANDOUT --
IT'LL START ON PAGE TWO MUCH OF
WHAT.
WE INCLUDING THE HEAD OUT HIS
BEEN COVERED BY -- SOME OF THE
OTHER PANELISTS SO I WILL MOVE
QUICKLY -- BUT ON THE TOP OF
PAGE TWO I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
AS WE PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE
FUNDING FORMULA LAST YEAR AND AS
WE CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT AND
THINK THROUGH -- POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE FORMULA WE'RE
GUIDED BY A SET OF THREE
PRINCIPLES ONE THE GOAL OF
ENCOURAGING PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS WHICH HAS A
NORTH STAR.
OF CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS --
EQUITY GAPS IN STUDENT OUTCOMES
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SECOND TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WHO HAVE FACED
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO SUCCESS.
PRINCIPALLY.
STUDENTS FROM LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS WITH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO MEET THE GOALS AND
THIRD TO MAKE THESE RESOURCES
FLEXIBLE AND PREDICTABLE -- AT
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWO HAS THE
STRUCTURE OF THE FORMULA THAT'S
BEEN COVERED SO I MOVED TO THE
TOP OF PAGE.
THREE AND JUST.
THE AGENDA NOTED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AROUND THE RELATIVE
DISTRIBUTION OF POINTS UNDER THE
FORMULA.
SO I THINK YOU CAN AND FOR THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH THE THE
POINTS WERE DESIGNED FIRST --
PARTICULARLY AS PART OF THE
STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION FIRST --
DIFFERENCES IN COST BASED ON
DIFFERENCES OF LIKE THE PROGRAM.
SECOND OF THE ADDED COSTS THE
DISTRICT MIGHT INCUR TOWARDS
INCREMENTAL PROGRESS TOWARD NOW
COME.
IN THIRD A CLEAR INTENT TO
CREATE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
AROUND PARTICULAR OUTCOMES I
THINK THIS IS MOST PROMINENT --
IN THE ADDITIONAL POINTS THAT
ARE AWARDED FOR A COMPLETION OF
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE -- THREE I
WOULD JUST KNOW WE HAVEN'T
TALKED YET ABOUT THE FUNDING
STABILITY PROVISIONS CLEARLY A A
GOAL OF THIS FORMULA WAS TO MAKE
OVER TIME -- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING MORE STABLE -- THE
FORMULA INCLUDES A SET OF TESTS
THAT DEFINE HOW MUCH A DISTRICT
WOULD RECEIVE IN A GIVEN YEAR
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
DISTRICT AS THE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS NOTED.
WOULD RECEIVE AT LEAST THERE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN READ
REVENUES ADJUSTED BY THE CHANGES
IN THE COST OF LIVING IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BEGINNING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WE SEE IT SORT OF TEST
THAT COMPARE WHAT A DISTRICT
WOULD HAVE RECEIVED.
UNDER THE STUDENT CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA IN THE CURRENT YEAR WITH
WHAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE IN THE
PRIOR YEAR AND WE FUND THEM AT
LEAST AT THE HIGHER OF THE TWO
MOVING ON TO PAGE FOUR I WOULD
JUST KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
SPLIT OF SEVENTY TWENTY TEN WHAT.
WE'RE SUGGESTING IS THAT THE
BASE ALLOCATION WOULD REPRESENT
STATEWIDE ABOUT 70% OF FUNDING
THE SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION 20%
THE STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION
10% -- BASED ON OUR MOST RECENT
ESTIMATE OF COSTS OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THAT'S GENERALLY WHAT
YOU SEE SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
OUTPUT ALLOCATED TOWARDS THE
BASE ALLOCATION -- AND THAT THE
SHARES DECLINING RAPIDLY BEYOND
THAT.
I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE -- FOR WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR ENACTED
THE FUNDING FOR THE LAST YEAR.
OF THE INCLUDED PROVISIONS
AROUND LOCAL GOAL SETTING
PLANNING AND AND BUDGETING WITH
THE INTENT THAT DISTRICTS AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO RESPOND TO
THE NEW INCENTIVES.
ARE HAVING A SET OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT.
HOW THOSE DOLLARS WOULD BE USED
TO SUPPORT ACHIEVEMENT OF THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS SPECIFICALLY
THE DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR THIS
ACADEMIC YEAR? TO ADOPT GOALS
THAT ARE ALLIED WITH THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS MOVING FORWARD WE
EXPECT AVOID OP COMPREHENSIVE
PLANS EDUCATIONAL PLANTS THAT
ALLIED WITH THOSE GOALS AND
OTHER BUDGETS WOULD BE ALLIED
WITH THOSE COMPREHENSIVE PLANS.
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE FIVE AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S NOTE -- NOTES -- AS OF
OUR MOST RECENT ESTIMATES OF THE
COST OF THE FORMULA -- THE KERN
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ARE
INSUFFICIENT TO COVER THE COST
OF THE FORMULA THERE'S TWO
PRINCIPAL REASONS THE TOTAL --
DIFFERENCE SAID AVAILABLE
RESOURCES IS -- THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR IN DOLLARS -- THE
DIFFERENCE IS -- OR IN TWO PARTS
ONE OF THE HIGHER COSTS OF THE
FORMULA OF ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS COMPARED
TO WHAT WAS ESTIMATED WHAT THE
BUDGET WAS ENACTED IN SHARED.
THIS LARGELY HAS TO DEAL WITH
BOTH INCREASES IN THE COST OF
THE STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION
ASSOCIATED WITH HIGHER THAN
PROJECTED OUTCOMES A STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
AS WELL AS INCREASES IN THE COST
OF THE HOLD HARMLESS THE
REVENUES THAT DISTRICTS RECEIVED
A TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WAS
HIGHER THAN WHAT WAS PROJECTED.
AND THEREFORE THE HOLD HARMLESS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS
HIGHER.
THE OTHER SOURCE OF THE
DIFFERENCE IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS --
ASSOCIATED WITH LOWER PROPERTY
TAX.
REVENUE COLLECTIONS THE WHAT WAS
ESTIMATED IN THE IN THE IN THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
THE EXTENT ARE ASK WOULD BE TO
THE EXTENT THAT PROPERTY TAXES
DON'T INCREASE -- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSISTED WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BACK FILL THE FUNDS HOW TO
ELIMINATE THAT PORTION OF THE
DEFICIT.
AS THE AS THE ANALYSTS NOTED --
IN COMMUNICATING THAT TO
DISTRICTS ABOUT WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE EXPECTING FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR WHICH AND SAID.
AND LESS THAN THREE MONTHS WE'VE
TOLD ALL DISTRICTS THAT
CONSISTENT WITH THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS OF THE
FUNDINGFORMULA.
DISTRICTS SHOULD EXPECT TO
RECEIVE AT LEAST THERE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REVENUES
ADJUSTED BY THE CHANGES THINGS
AND THE COST OF LIVING.
ALL CLOSE ON PAGE -- SIX IN
RESPONSE -- TO CONCERNS THE
CHANCELLOR'S HAD CONCERNS WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE FIELD IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS -- THE
CHANCELLOR ASTON ADVISORY
WORKGROUP ON FISCAL AFFAIRS TO
LOOK AT SOME ISSUES RELATED TO
THE FUNDING FORMULA AND TO
ADVISE HIM ON AMENDMENTS. TO THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA --
INCLUDING FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY HAVING BROKEN THOSE
ISSUES OUT INTO TWO CATEGORIES
THE FIRST IS STRUCTURAL ISSUES.
OTHER PROBABLY THREE QUESTIONS
WERE LOOKING THEIR FIRST --
CONSISTENT WITH THE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HOW SHOULD
THE FORMULA CAN STRAIGHT YEAR TO
YEAR INCREASES -- IN REVENUES
ARE GIVEN THE STATE'S --
CONSTRAINTS AND REVENUES SECOND
HOW DO WE DETERMINE WHAT DATA TO
PULL FROM -- CURRENTLY THE
FUNDING FORMULA USES PRIOR YEAR
DATA -- FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION OF FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION.
IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED GIVEN OUR
DESIRE FOR MORE CERTAINTY THAT
WE USE UP.
EVEN -- PRIOR YEAR DATA -- TO TO
CALCULATE DISTRICT APPORTIONMENT.
AND THEN WHICH GROUPS OF
STUDENTS ARE INTENDED TO BE
SUPPORTED CURRENTLY -- WE'VE
MADE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR OF MADE DECISIONS ABOUT
DIFFERENT FUNDING ALLOCATIONS
INCLUDING FOR STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN CREDIT STUDENTS IN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THE SECOND SET OF ISSUES RELATED
TO THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION THE FIRST THE ALEJO
MENTION ALREADY HOUSE OF THE
FORMULAE COUNT FOR STUDENTS WHO
ALL OCCURRED MORE THAN ONE AWARD
IN A GIVEN YEAR. TO WATCH
DISTRICTS CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S.
A PROPOSAL SHOULD POST COLLEGE
OUTCOMES LIKE TRANSFER TO A FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTION BE ATTRIBUTED.
AND HOW MIGHT THE DEFINITIONS OF
THESE MEASURES BETTER BE REFINED --
TO TO ACCOUNT FOR THE GOALS THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
AND THEN FINALLY AS BOTH THE
GOVERNOR HAS NOTED EMILIO --
REFERENCED -- THE CHANCELLOR IS
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THERE ARE -- IT'S CONFIDENCE IN
BOTH THE RELIED BILLION THE
VALIDITY OF THE DATA THAT'S
BEING USED IN THE FUNDING
FORMULA.
WE'VE CONTRACTED WITH THE FISCAL
CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAM TO REVIEW THE DATA AT A
SUBSET OF COLLEGES AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US.
BASED ON COMMON PRACTICES AND
BEST PRACTICES OF THE COLLEGES
WE EXPECT TO RECEIVE A REPORT
LATER THIS MONTH -- WITH THE
GOAL THAT I COULD INFORM NEW
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AND POTENTIAL OUT OF
PROCEDURES.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- YEAH SORRY MR
BROUGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER QUESTION FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES COUPLE
WEEKS AGO HAD SOME VETERANS
STUDENTS HAVE SATELLITE COLLEGE
IN MY DISTRICT -- THEY WERE
INFORMING ME OF A A REQUEST FOR
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTERS BUT
THERE'S FIVE MILLION.
IN YOUR PROPOSAL IS CAN YOU TELL
ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT --
THERE'S BEEN FUNDING IN PRIOR
YEARS -- THERE'S NO FUNDING AND
AND THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS FOR
CLASS -- AND NO FUNDING AND
SPECIFICALLY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- WHAT I WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW I THINK IT IS CLEARLY A
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED AS -- HAVING --
LIKELY BARRIERS TO SUCCESS IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS PART
OF OUR STUDENT EQUITY IN A
TREATMENT PROGRAM A LARGE.
PART OF FUNDS THAT COLLEGES HAVE
AVAILABLE TO OUGHT TO ADDRESS
EQUITY GAPS.
VETERANS OF OURS ARE IDENTIFIED
AS A CATEGORY OF STUDENTS THAT
COLLEGES SHOULD BE PLANNING FOR
A PARTICULAR SERVICES. TO ASSIST
TWENTY MILLION FUNDED PREVIOUSLY
BUT JUST NOT FUNNY NOW -- THERE --
THERE'S BEEN ONE TIME FUNDING IN
RECENT YEARS.
THE NUMBERS ARE ESCAPING ME AND
I DON'T OF FINANCE -- THE LA
AWESOME UP TOP MY THERE HAD IF
YOU I THINK IT IS IF IT CAN GET
BACK TO US ON THE AND IT AND
IT'S CERTAINLY WE WE'VE RECEIVED
THE REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- IN THE BUDGET YEAR WE
DID NOT INCLUDED IN OUR REQUEST
GIVE IN -- BUT BROADER
PHILOSOPHY THAT OUT COLLEGES
SHOULD BE PLANNING FOR OF THE
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS
THAT HAVE THE GREATEST NAY
FULLER CAUGHT UP THEIR CAMPUSES
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS -- A
I REALIZE THE FUNDING FORMULAS
NEW I'M NOT SURE.
I HOPE WE'RE GONNA USE I STEPHEN
DECATUR GONNA TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS AND WE REALLY NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT IT BECAUSE I'M NOT
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING IT RIGHT
AT THIS POINT -- WE'VE GOT A
SHORT TOLD WHAT THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION IS THAT
CORRECT.
BUT THAT'S A PROJECTION I WOULD
SAY THINK -- PART OF THAT THE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION IS MORE --
BUT I THINK THEY'RE THERE FOR
TWO DIFFERENT REASONS A LARGE
TAX ISSUES FOR THE TAX ISSUES I
THINK ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE SO
THAT'S A TWO AND IT WAS JUST.
FOR FOR ARGUMENT'S SAKE SO WHERE
WOULD THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
COME FROM I MEAN THERE'S GOING
FORWARD DO YOU WANT US TO GIVE
THAT TO YOU.
DO YOU UNIFIED THAT WITHIN YOUR
OWN SYSTEM ARE YOU GONNA GO BACK
AND RE BENCH WOULD YOU PROMISED
PREVIOUSLY WOULD WHAT'S YOUR
STRATEGY.
YES I WOULD SAY -- THERE I THINK
THERE ARE THERE IS A CLEAR
REQUEST FROM OUR OFFICE THAT THE
STATE -- PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
APPRPRIATIONS TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THE FORMULA BUT WHATEVER
THAT DEFICIT -- ULTIMATELY WOULD
BE -- WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
HISTORIC PRACTICE OR THE
PRACTICE OF THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS HAS BEEN TO FIND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CONSISTENT WITH THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE SO WE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT'S THE REALITY
THAT WE ARE -- PLAYING IN A
FIXED -- A LOT OF FUN SO I THINK --
YOU KNOW.
IN TALKING WITH FOLKS THROUGHOUT
THE SYSTEM I THINK THERE IS A
<c.green>LEAR MESSAGE THAT WE NEED TO</c>
HAVE A MUCH STRONGER MESSAGE
THAT THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS
INSUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
RESOURCES.
OF THE RESOURCE NEEDS OF THE
COLLEGES BUT IT BUT YES I THINK
ULTIMATELY -- AT THE REQUEST AS
THE STATE SHOULD BACK FILL OUT
WHATEVER THE FORMULA COSTS AND
MOVING FORWARD WE SHOULD
IDENTIFY.
HOW TO ADJUST THE FORMULA TO FIT
WITHIN THE RESOURCE NEEDS THAT
ARE -- REASONABLE FOR THE STATE
TO PROVIDE.
THE RESOURCE IS MAYBE NOT EVEN
THE RESOURCE -- I WOULD SAY THE
RESOURCES BECAUSE THE NEED IS
GREATER THAN OR ALLOCATING AYE
AYE I CONCEDE THAT OUT OF THE
GATE BUT GIVEN THE CONFINES WE
HAVE WITH.
K. FOURTEEN PROP NINETY EIGHT
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO
MAKE IT A CEILING AS OPPOSED TO
A FLOOR.
AND THAT'S OUR DECISION AND I
THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE IT'S NOT
ON AYE SUPPORT BUT IT IS IT IS A
FACT.
THAT THE DYNAMIC WE LIVE IN --
FOR THE JOB IN FOR A SECOND --
WE WE THINK THAT THE THAT THERE
ARE A FEW EXPLANATIONS FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE REPORTED
CURRENT YEAR APPORTIONMENT
SHORTFALL -- WITH.
HISTORICAL TRENDS IN RECENT
YEARS -- YOU CAN SEE THAT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THE THE
CHANCELLR'S OFFICE PROPERTY
TAXES HAVE BEEN.
UNDER REPORTED IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAT THE P. ONE POINT IN
TIME AND THAT'S LARGELY RELATED
TO WHEN PROPERTY TAXES ARE
COLLECTED -- FOR P. ONE AND THE
LAST THREE YEARS -- PROPERTY
TAXES HAVE BEEN.
UNDER REPORTED BY YOU KNOW CLOSE
TO A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS AND WE
ALSO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME.
OTHER EXPLANATION SUCH AS THE IN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
CALCULATION OF EXPENDITURES FOR
THEIR CURRENT YEAR SHORTFALL WE
THINK THERE'S SOME OVERSTATING
OF EXPENDITURES INCLUDING -- A
MISCALCULATION OF THAT THREE
YEAR AVERAGE FOR THE BASE
ALLOCATION OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA -- AND THE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ALSO.
IT USES A DEFINITION OF
TRANSFERS THAT DOES NOT ALIGN
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO ACCOUNT FOR AND
DUPLICATED TRANSFERS AND SO FOR
A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS WE
THINK -- THAT THE REPORTED
SHORTFALL IN THE CURRENT YEAR IS
IS NOT AS GREAT AS IS.
CURRENTLY BEING STATED SO WOULD
WE FIX THIS WHERE WOULD WE
ADDRESS THAT IN THE BUDGET.
YEAH RIGHT NOW WE ARE -- ME THE
ART OF DANCE IS A LOT OF SWAY
HER SOMEONE EARNED.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST TALKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE GET TO A
SOLUTION SO THAT THEY DON'T DO
THAT AGAIN IF IN FACT THEY ARE
DOING AND MISSING YOUR DOING
THAT BUT IF THAT'S HAPPENING.
THERE'S ACCOUNTING.
YEAH WE WERE UPDATING
EXPENDITURES AS WE ARE A LEADING
UP TO THE MAY REVISION WHICH IS
THIS COMING UP VERY SOON WORK
WE'RE GOING TO BE RECEIVING.
UPDATED REVENUES SO WE ARE
MONITORING YOU KNOW THIS THE
SITUATION VERY CLOSELY -- OKAY.
THE DIED IN DID YOU WANT TO ADD
SOMETHING.
I'M RICHARD HE THOUGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
DATA WE HAVE UPDATED DATE AT
THAT WE RECEIVE AT THE MERE
VISION.
AND TYPICALLY WHEN THERE ARE
SHIPS AND PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
AT THE ME REVISION -- A FINANCE
PROPOSES THAT MAKES A FINE SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE DATA THAT
THE MAY REVISED MAY ADDRESS THE
SITUATION BECAUSE I YEAH I HAVE
A CHALLENGE OF THE YOU KNOW.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE COME EVER
SAY LOOK WE HAVE THIS BIG
SHORTFALL AND THEN YOU GUYS A
WAY MAYBE THEY DON'T I JUST HOPE
THIS WILL BE WORKED OUT PRIOR TO
THIS HEARING GOING FORWARD
THAT'S JUST MY TAKE.
BUT EITHER WAY -- THANK YOU AND
I JUST COUPLE OTHER -- OF
THOUGHTS QUESTIONS YOU KNOW WITH
REGARD TO THE CURRENT FUNDING
FORMULA IS IT IS UNPREDICTABLE.
IT BOUNCES TOO MUCH I THINK WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT IT'S
COMPLEX TO IMPLEMENT -- IT EVEN
THE LA -- SAYS IT COULD
FLUCTUATE GREATLY FROM ONE YEAR
TO ANOTHER SO I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT AS YOU AS YOU
CONTEMPLATE SOME CHANGES. TO THE
FUNDING FORMULA AND THE STUDENT
SUCCESS MEASURES CONCERN ME
GREATLY BECAUSE THE USE IT
STUDENT WHO TRANSFERS TO UC
GENERATES LESS FUNDING THAN A
TRANSFER TO A CSU BECAUSE THAT
ASSOCIATES.
DEGREE REQUIREMENT WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BOTHERING FOR
SOMETIME THE CHANCES ARE CAME
DOWN AND TALK TO MY OFFICE.
MANAGER WELL -- IN -- YOU KNOW.
I THOUGHT ALLAY MY CONCERNS BUT
THEY'RE BACK AS TO WHY WE'RE
EVEN REQUIRING AN A AD
TRANSFERRING THAT SEEMS ODD TO
ME THAT WE WORK WE REQUIRE THAT.
BECAUSE LOOKS LIKE THERE.
IS FOR ONE AGAIN WHEN A STUDENT
TRANSFERS TO THE TO SEE ISSUE.
IT SCORE HIGHER.
ON THE INDICATORS AND OF A
STUDENT TRANSFERS TO THE UC AND
WONDERING WHY THAT IS.
AND AGAIN I'M STILL WONDERING GO
BACK TO WHY WE HAVE THE A AND
AND YOU CAN EVEN DANCES AT SIXTY
UNITS IS FIFTY SIX WAS A FIFTY
SIX IS THE MINIMUM REQUIRED AS A
TO TRANSFER AS A AS I I I RECALL --
BUT IF THE OTHER QUESTION I WITH
GUARDED THIS FORMULA AND THE AND
AND AND THAT AND THE MEASURES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT ARE.
WOULD IT PROMOTE AND CREATE.
THE A A WHAT IT -- WITH THE
COLLEGE.
GAME THE SYSTEM BY CREATING
SHORT TERM CERTIFICATES THAT
DON'T REALLY DO MUCH FOR
STUDENTS.
TO INSURE REVENUE GROWTH.
AND YOU WANT TO SPEAK.
TO BUILDING OUR HEART OF THAT --
SO YOU KNOW I THINK WE'VE TALKED
IN THE PAST ABOUT -- YOU KNOW
THE THE EXPECTATION AROUND A
TRANSFER WITH AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE -- BUT WE WOULD SAY
WITHOUT THE FUNDING FORMULA DOES
NOT REQUIRE IT IT CERTAINLY
CREATES AN INCENTIVE FOR
COLLEGES.
TO BUT STUDENTS ON A PATH
TOWARDS IN AT T..
THE RATIONALE BEING THAT
STUDENTS.
ON A PATH TOWARDS IN AT T. OUR
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
DECIDE UP FRONT WHEN THEY HAVE A
GOAL TO TRANSFER WHERE
SPECIFICALLY THEY WANT TO
TRANSFER.
THAT IN AT T. PROVIDES GREATER
OPTIONS THE SYSTEMS WORKING WITH
YOU SEE AN WITH INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
AT T. AS A RECOGNIZE TRANSFER
PATHWAY FOR THOSE INSTITUTIONS --
IT MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS LEAVE
THE COLLEGES WITH A DEGREE IN
CASE THEY TRANSFER NOT DON'T
ULTIMATELY EARNED A DEGREE IT
GIVES THEM SOME GUARANTEES A PAY
ATTENDED THE CSU.
RECOGNIZING YOUR CONCERNS I
THINK THERE ARE -- THERE ARE
POLICY WERE -- REASONS
PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS THAT WE
THINK.
LEAVING WITH AT T. PROVIDE REAL
QUICK IMAGE OVER THERE SO THAT
IF I'M A COLLEGE I'M I'M I'M A
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I'M GOING
INCENTIVIZE OF STUDENTS FROM THE
ASSOCIATE.
THE A A PATH I MIGHT EVEN GIVE
THEM CLASSES BEFORE I GIVE
STUDENTS WHO AREN'T ON THE A
PATH RIGHT.
THAT'S A PROBLEM ISN'T IT.
AND I THINK THE YOU KNOW THE THE
THE RESPONSE MIGHT BE FOR
STUDENTS WHO ENTER THE COLLEGE
WITH AN EDUCATIONAL GOAL OF
TRANSFER THERE SHOULD BE ONE
PATH THERE SHOULD NOT BE A
MULTIPLE PATHS THAT.
A TRANSFER STUDENT WHO WANTS TO
EARN AN A A TRANSFER STUDENT WHO
WANTS TO SIMPLY TRANSFER WITHOUT
A DEGREE SO I THINK THE GOAL IS
HOW DO YOU MAKE THE AT T. --
YEAH THE LEGISLATION -- LIMITS
THE NUMBER OF UNITS IN AT T. AND
THE GOAL IS TO SAY -- STUDENT
SHOULD WHO SEEK TO TRANSFER
SHOULD HAVE A A CLEAR PATHWAY TO
TRANSFER BASED ON THE ACADEMIC
PROGRAM THERE AND NOT BASED ON
THE INSTITUTION OF THEIR THAT
THEY ARE SEEKING TO TRANSFER --
TO COULD YOU RECALL COULD THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY HAVE A
EIGHT FORCE THE JAKE UNITS THAT
THEY MIGHT NOT EVEN NEED.
I WOULD IMAGINE THERE'S A CASE
THAT THAT -- I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY THE CASE IN
SOME INSTANCES BUT I THINK IT'S
TYPICAL WHAT'S THAT IT'S NOT A
TYPICAL EXPERIENCE.
I WOULD ARGUE IT'S NOT TYPICAL
BUT I THINK THERE ARE FACULTY
AND OTHERS HERE WHO PROBABLY --
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT WORLD DAY
TODAY.
IT COULD PROBABLY ANSWER THAT.
WE KEEP ON I'M SO I CUT YOU OFF
OF NATO AND AND AND I AM --
LOOKING -- FOR FOR MY NOTES ON
YOUR SECOND QUESTION -- COULD
YOU REMIND ME OF THE THE SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION -- IT HAD
TO DO WITH INCENTIVIZE SOME
COLLEGES BEING INCENTIVIZE THE
TABLE BELOW VALUE CREATE --
SHORT TERM CERTIFICATES TO
PROMOTE STUDENT YOU KNOW YEAH
RAPID STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT TESTS.
MORE DOLLARS I THINK IT'S WHAT
I'M PART YOU KNOW WHAT WE SAID
IN THE BEGINNING AS WE NEED TO
REVIEW THE FORMALIN SO MOVING
FORWARD I THINK THAT'S A CLEAR --
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE -- BEEN
PARTNERING WITH OUTSIDE
RESEARCHERS TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND IS WHAT IMPACT DOES
THIS FORMULA HAVE.
ON THE OUTCOMES THAT OUR
STUDENTS ATTAIN -- I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT -- IT I THINK.
THIS FUNDING FORMULA LIVES --
NEXT TO WITHIN -- A VARIETY OF
OTHER PROCESS SEES INCLUDING --
PROCESSES RELATED TO THE
APPROVAL OF DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES THAT ARE INTENDED
TO ENSURE PROGRAM INTEGRITY --
AND SO -- WE THINK THAT THERE
ARE PROTECTIONS IN THE SYSTEM
BUT AGAIN -- SO THERE
PROTECTIONS -- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY AROUND THE APPROVAL OF
THOSE PROGRAMS WHETHER IT
CHANGES -- HOW COLLEGES?
PUT STUDENTS ON A PATHWAY AND
WHETHER COLLEGES PUT MORE
STUDENTS ON A PATHWAY TO A SHORT
TERM CERTIFICATE.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE OTHER
PROTECTIONS AND CERTAINLY
INCENTIVES -- AND THE FUNDING
FORMULA.
THAT ASSIGN DIFFERENT VALUE TO
DIFFERENT CREDENTIALS BASED ON
BASED ON THE LENGTH OF DEGREE
AND AND CERTAINLY THE LABOR
MARKET VALUE OF THE DEGREE.
AND SO -- WE THINK THAT THERE
ARE WE THINK THE INCENTIVES A
LOT OUR LINE WE THINK THERE
PROTECTIONS BUT CERTAINLY WILL
CONTINUE TO REVIEW.
THERE WAS SOMETHING SOMETHING UP
A LEGITIMATE BUT SOMETHING'S.
I MAYBE THE WORDS WRONG HERE IF
WE END UP WITH A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT GIVE OR
TAKE.
RIGHT I MEAN THERE THE MATH
SOMEWHERE IS WRONG.
FORMULA SOMEWHERE IS WRONG I
THINK WE'D ALL CONCEDE THAT.
I THINK THE YOU KNOW I THINK.
BUT I THINK WHAT IT SUGGESTS IS
THAT IN DESIGNING THE FORMULA --
THE PER -- WORKLOAD MEASURE RATE --
MAY HAVE NEEDED TO BE REFINED
PLASTER.
JUST.
ON THE ON THIS ISSUE OF SORT OF
CERTIFICATE THAT THE THINK.
UPON I THINK I THINK THERE IS
THERE IS GOOD REASON TO WANT TO
HONOR THE THIS ISSUE BECAUSE A
BIG I I AGREE SOME LIBERAL DON'T
AT THIS THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE THOUGHT OF AS A BIGGER
CONCERN WITH THE FORMULATE TERMS
OF WHERE.
THERE COULD BE GAMING IS THE
ISSUE OF THE SORT OF THE LOWER
UNIT CERTIFICATES THAT COULD BE
A PLACE WHERE COLLEGES THAT'S
BEEN THE RESOURCES WE THINK THAT
THE RECOMMENDATION THAT WE
SUGGEST -- AND I THINK OTHER
GROUPS OF THE JUST AS WELL OF
CAPPING THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT THAT
YOU COULD RECEIVE FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT AT WHATEVER
THE HIGHEST JUST THE THE HIGHEST
OUTCOME EARNED.
IS ONE WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT
ISSUE SAY IF YOU HAVE A STUDENT
IS GETTING AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE.
YOU KNOW TAKING ON ADDITIONAL
CERTIFICATES ISN'T NECESSARILY
GOING TO ADD ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THAT THE CAM BECAUSE
DISTRICT THAT'S I THINK WE THINK
THAT COULD BE ONE WAY TO ADDRESS
THAT.
I WOULD SAY ALSO ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS I KNOW WE FOR WE HEARD
ABOUT SOME CONCERNS WITH
COMPLEXITY OF THE FORMULA AND
WHY DON'T WE SIMPLIFY IT SO THAT
AFTER THE EVERY OUTCOME GETS THE
SAME AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT IF WE DID
THAT I WOULD HAVE MORE CONCERNS
WITH THOSE SPECIFIC ISSUES
BECAUSE IN THAT CASE THEN YOU
WOULD HAVE AN EIGHTEEN UNITS
CERTIFICATE THAT HAS THE SAME
VALUE ESTATE SOMEONE WHO
TRANSFERRED OR SOMEONE WHO GETS
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE.
IF THAT'S THE WAY WE WOULD
CREATE FOR NOT THAT I THINK THAT
WE WOULD START TO BE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE NOW.
AS THEY CAN BECAUSE DISTRICT YOU
GET THE SAME OUTCOMES FOR
GETTING SOMEBODY TO AN EIGHTEEN
UNIT PROGRAM.
AS SOMEONE WHO GOES TO A SIXTY
UNIT PROGRAM SO THAT'S I THINK
WHY THERE IS.
IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
MONITOR WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ALL
THESE HOW DO WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN THE RIGHT VALUES FOR EACH
OF THEM IS VERY DIFFICULT.
BUT IF WE DO -- ARE WE IF WE
HAVE A SIMPLE MORE SIMPLIFIED
SYSTEM THAT IS A BOARDING
EVERYBODY ABOUT THE SAME AMOUNT
OF WHEN.
THE AMOUNT OF WORK REQUIRED TO
GET THESE DIFFERENT DEGREES IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAT COULD BE
MORE PROBLEMATIC AND THE TERMS
OF JUST.
HOW HOW COLLEGES MIGHT RESPOND?
YEAH LET ME JUST WE INTEND TO
MAKE A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
YOU ALL BY THE END OF THE MONTH
ABOUT CHANGES TO THE FORMULA --
WE HAVE VETTED OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
PROPOSAL ON COUNTING ONLY THE
HIGHEST AWARD WITH A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS INCLUDING OUR
CONSULTATION COUNCIL I THINK IT
IS A RECOMMENDATION THAT WE WILL
BE SUPPORTIVE OF RECOMMENDATIONS
TO US WITH.
THIS THE THE THE THE FORMULAS AN
ANIMAL OF THE CHANCE OR SALAS
CRACKED IT IS SPECIFIED IN
STATUTE IT IS IT IS OKAY YEAR IT
DID THAT THEY THE EXISTING
STRUCTURES SPECIFIED STATURE YES
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I WILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND BRING UP -- ISSUE TO THE
PROMISE PROGRAM
.
AND AND I APOLOGIZE OF A I
DIDN'T SEE ON MYON MY AGENDA
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY TWO PANELS
ON THE ON THE PANEL PROGRAM --
THE FIRST ONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
EXCUSE ME CHANCELLOR.
MY BAD AS THEY SAY.
I'LL CALL YOU BACK [inaudible]
MAY BEGIN.
MORNING AGAIN MICHELLE NEW IN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT A SECOND YEAR
FREE TUITION.
BY EXTENDING THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISED TO FIRST TIME
FULL TIME STUDENTS IN THEIR
SECOND ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL BUILT ON CURRENT
LAW AS ESTABLISHED BY AB
NINETEEN WHICH ITSELF
ESTABLISHED CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE.
AND ALLOWS COLLEGES TO WAIVE
FEES FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF
COLLEGE FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
DOES NOT CHANGE ANY OF THE
EXISTING PROVISIONS OF THE
CURRENT LAW EXCEPT FOR EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM TO A SECOND ACADEMIC
YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO EXPAND
OUT REACH AROUND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE.
BY ESTABLISHING THE STUDENT
SUCCESS AWARENESS INITIATIVE.
AS MORE COLLEGES IMPLEMENT
PROMISE PROGRAMS THERE IS A NEED
TO ENSURE THAT COLLEGES CAN
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE TO
STUDENTS INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
PROMISE PROGRAMS.
THE COST OF COLLEGE IN THEIR
FINANCIAL AID OPPORTUNITIES.
AND THERE PATHWAYS TO SUCCESS.
THIS FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THAT NEED.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
FURTHER QUESTIONS.
AND IF WE COULD GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU LISA
CAN LET LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
ALL THESE PEOPLE FROM YOUR
DENTIST STARTING ON PAGE.
THIRTEEN THE STATE HAS A LONG
STANDING PROGRAM CALLED THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS FEE WAIVER
THAT COVERS ENROLLMENT FEES FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE FINANCIAL NEED
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
CURRENTLY OVER 40% OF COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS RECEIVED AT THE
RIVER TRADITIONAL BASED PROGRAM.
AS YOU RECALL THE STATE RECENTLY
EXPANDED FEE WAIVERS TO CERTAIN
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT HAVE
FINANCIAL NEED SPECIFICALLY
FIRST TIME STUDENTS WHO ARE
ENROLLED FULL TIME.
AND IN THE FIRST YEAR OF COLLEGE.
AND NOT PROGRAM IS CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
THE STATE FIRST FUNDED THIS
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR FUNDS UNDER
THIS PROGRAM COLLEGES MUST MEET
SIX REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO SKIN
SUPPORT.
BUT YOU'RE LISTED IN THE MIDDLE
OF PAGE FOURTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
IN THIS SENSE THE PROGRAM IS
ALSO INTENDED TO SERVE AS AN
INCENTIVE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE SPACE [inaudible]
COLLEGES CLOSER.
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
SHARED THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
AN AUGMENTATION OF FORTY MILLION
AND BETWEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET.
THAT WOULD ALLOW COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE FEE WAIVERS FOR FIRST
TIME FULL TIME STUDENTS WITHOUT
FINANCIAL NEED IN THEIR SECOND
YEAR OF COLLEGE.
OUR OFFICE DOES HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONSENSUS THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
ARE SUMMARIZED ON PAGE FIFTEEN
OF YOUR AGENDA.
TOWARD THE MIDDLE OF THE PAGE.
OUR FIRST CONCERN IS PRIMARILY A
MATTER OF TIMING.
BECAUSE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
IS THE FIRST YEAR IN WHICH THE
STATE IS FUNDED THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM WE DO NOT YET
HAVE SUFFICIENT OUTCOMES TEST
TEST IMPACT ON ENROLLMENT
FINANCIAL AID PARTICIPATION AND
OTHER STUDENT OUTCOMES.
AND ABOUT A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
PERFORMING WE THINK IT MAY BE
PREMATURE TO SUBSTANTIALLY
EXPAND FUNDING FOR IT.
I SECOND CONCERN IS MORE
DISTRIBUTIONAL IN NATURE.
THERE IS CURRENTLY A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF ON MATT FINANCIAL NEED
AMONG COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
NON TUITION COSTS WHICH ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FEE WAIVERS FOR NEEDY
STUDENTS.
IF THE GOAL IS TO INCREASE
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY THAN WE
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
PRIORITIZE ADDRESSING THE
EXISTING ON MIGHT NEED.
BEFORE EXPANDING IT FOR STUDENTS
WHO DO NOT DEMONSTRATE NEED.
FINALLY OUR THIRD POINT JUST
RETURNS TO THE IDEA THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO
SERVE AS AN INCENTIVE FOR
COLLEGES TO IMPROVE STUDENT
SUPPORT.
HERE WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
SINCE CREATING THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALSO ENACTED SEVERAL OTHER
REFORMS INCLUDING THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA.
THAT PROVIDE EVEN LARGER FISCAL
INCENTIVES FOR COLLEGES TO
ENHANCE STUDENT SUPPORT. FOR
THESE REASONS OUR OFFICE DOES
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
REDIRECTING THE FORTY MILLION
PROPOSED FUNDING TOWARD OTHER
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PRIORITIES.
AS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
EXPLAINS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES ALSO
INCLUDE F. RELATED POSTS ALL OF
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME FOR
OUTREACH RELATED TO THE COLLEGE
PROMISE AND OTHER STUDENTS
SUPPORT INITIATIVES.
OUR OFFICE IS CURRENTLY
ASSESSING THIS PROPOSAL AND WILL
BE SURE TO KEEP FACTORED DATED
AS WE COMPLETE OUR RIGHT AT
THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU CHRISTMAS WHENEVER THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
WILL START ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
HAND OUT -- AND WE'VE TAKEN A
SLIGHTLY BROADER IF YOU JUST
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT.
ABOUT WHAT THE ISSUES ARE THAT
THE COLLEGE PROMISES INTENDED TO
SOLVE.
BUT ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE SEVEN
I THINK ONE WAY -- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO DESCRIBE
WHO ENROLLS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WHO OUR STUDENTS ARE.
OUT TO WAYS OF DESCRIBING THEM
THAT I THINK ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT -- FOR THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE PROMISE
OF OUR THEIR AGE THAT NEARLY
MORE THAN 40% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE
WE TEND TO SERVE.
A POPULATION OF STUDENTS THAT
SKEWS OLDER SKEWS -- CERTAINLY A
POPULATION OF STUDENTS THAT --
IS SIGNIFICANT IS NOT COMING TO
US DIRECTLY OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
A SECOND WE SERVE A A VERY
DIVERSE POPULATION OF STUDENTS
THE REVERSE MOST DIVERSE
POPULATION OF STUDENTS ACROSS
SEGMENTS -- HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH NEARLY HALF OF OUR STUDENTS
IDENTIFYING AS LATIN ACTS.
IF YOU MOVE ON TO PAGE -- EIGHT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT -- THE
HISTORY OF ENROLLMENT FEES AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND DAD
ENROLLMENT FEES TODAY OR FORTY
SIX DOLLARS PER UNIT SPECIFIED
IN STATUTE THE LOWEST IN THE US --
BUT MOST STILL -- NEARLY HALF OF
STUDENTS TO MOST OF UNITS ARE
WAIVED UNDER THE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT.
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE EIGHT WE
SHOW THAT -- THE ROMAN FEES ARE
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE.
BUT THEY ARE A SMALL PART OF FOR
BOTH STUDENTS WHO ARE IDENTIFIED
AS LIVING AT HOME AND THOSE WHO
ARE LIVING AWAY FROM HOME WE
SHOW -- FOR ONE COLLEGE TOTAL
COSTS THERE -- THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR STUDENTS LIVING AT
HOME TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR STUDENTS -- AWAY
FROM HOME FOR STUDENT ATTENDING
FULL TIME THAT THIRTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS -- TUITION IN -- FOR THE
YEAR IS LESS THAN 10% OF THE
TOTAL COST OF THAT THEY FACE AND
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE TOP OF
PAGE -- NINE WE INCLUDE AN
ANALYSIS PERFORMED BY THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS THAT SHOWS THAT -- FOR
STUDENTS ACROSS THE REGIONS
WHERE THERE IS A UC CAMPUS.
IN NONE OF THE REGIONS IS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE LOWEST
THAT PRICE FOR THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND IN SEVEN OF THE REGION'S IT
IT IS THE HIGHEST COST COMPARED
TO THE UC IN THE CSU.
AND SO WITH THAT WE BUT AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE NINE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CAL COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM.
AND I WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT INCLUDED WITH
THE PROGRAM THAT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THE INTENT INCLUDED IN OUR
VISION FOR SUCCESS TO INCLUDE --
TO INCREASE COLLEGE PREPARATION
IMPROVE PREPARATION FOR JOBS
INCREASE TRANSFER FROM THE UC
OUT TO THE YOU SEE IN THE CSU.
AND TO ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS
BOTH ACROSS GROUPS OF STUDENTS
BUT ALSO ACROSS REGIONS OF THE
STATE.
AND SO AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST AND THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HAVE DESCRIBED THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF REQUIREMENTS IN AB
NINETEEN TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM.
AND THE STATUTE AUTHORIZES BUT
NOT DOES NOT REQUIRE THAT
COLLEGES -- WAIVE FEES FOR FIRST
TIME FULL TIME STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT ALREADY RECEIVE FEE WAIVERS.
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TEN WE
SHOW HOW WE ALLOCATED THE FUNDS
SO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED
FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
OUT WE USED -- FIRST AS THE
PRIMARY CRITERIA -- THE NUMBER
OF UNITS AT A COLLEGE THAT WERE
NOT WAIVED UNDER THE EXISTING
FEE WAIVER POLICIES -- THAT WAS
ABOUT THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE ALLOCATION WITH THE
REMAINING FUNDS WE ALLOCATED
THAT TO COLLEGES BASED ON THEIR
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AND THEIR COUNTS OF
POWDERED RECIPIENTS. FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED FUNDING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE WOULD EXPECT
THAT WE WOULD ALL THE ALLOCATE
THE FUNDING BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF FIRST TIME FULL TIME STUDENTS.
NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING FEE
WAIVERS.
I'M AND THEN TO CLOSE ON THE
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY -- FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN A HUNDRED FIVE COLLEGES
CHOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM MOST USED AT LEAST PART
OF THEIR MONEY FOR FEE WAIVERS
FOR THOSE FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT CURRENTLY
RECEIVE THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE GRANT.
SOME COLLEGES DID USE MONEY --
FOR GRANTS FOR NOT TUITION COSTS
INCLUDING FOOD TRANSPORTATION
AND BOOKS -- AND SOME COLLEGES
USED -- FOR FUNDING FOR SUPPORT
SERVICES LIKE COUNSELORS AND
ADVISERS WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
A NINE COLLEGES THAT CHOSE NOT
TO PARTICIPATE IN -- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO WORK WITH
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY WE BELIEVE THAT
AT LEAST FOR WILL PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM -- IN THE COMING
YEAR.
AND THEN WITH REGARD TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND THE
STUDENT SUCCESS AWARENESS AND IF
ADDITION OF WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PROPOSAL -- WE BELIEVE THAT
IF MESSAGING IMPROVE MESSAGING
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF HOW
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAMS WORK --
THEN WE NEED TO DO MORE WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE RECEIVE A COHERENT
MESSAGE ABOUT WHAT COLLEGE
PROMISE MEANS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
SECOND PANEL HERE HEARING FROM
SOME.
I'LL JUST ACROSS CALIFORNIA
BEFORE WE GET TO THE Q. AND A
WE'RE MISSING THE SANTA BARBARA.
PERSON WAS YOUR PERSON.
LIMóN.
OKAY SO IS HERE.
OKAY YES I KNOW WE HAD A GREAT.
CONVERSATION WITH THEM IN SANTA
BARBARA SAY WHEN A GET THEIR
PERSPECTIVE UP HERE.
SO WITH THAT WILL BEGIN WITH --
PARTS ANSWER FROM LOS ANGELES AS
WELL AS IT ARE -- SUPERINTENDENT
PRESIDENT FROM LAKE TAHOE SO
WELCOME BACK TO SACRAMENTO.
YES THE MORNING AT YOUR PARTY
MEMBERS OF THE THIS IS FOR THESE
JOBS FROM LOS ANGELES
[inaudible]
MR.
THE ONLY PROBLEM ON THE OTHER
THE ONLY BECAUSE DISTRICT
WHATEVER SEIZE.
OUR STUDENTS ARE NINE POLITICS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND SUPPORT.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA COME FROM THIS
PROGRAM.
HE'S VERY DELIVER ON OF BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA WILL SEE THE
BENEFITS OF YOUR INVESTMENT
GENERATIONS.
LOS ANGELES THE LA THIS PROGRAM
IS MUCH MORE.
THAN THREE TUITION.
THE ONLY CAUSE PROBLEMS FOR
ORGANIZATIONS ACCESS PROGRAM
WELL.
BASED ON A NATIONWIDE BEST
PRACTICES.
TODAY THE PROGRAM SERVES NEARLY
NINE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
AND REQUIRES FULL TIME ROLE IN A
STRUCTURED EDUCATIONAL PLAN IS
NOT AN ENGLISH.
APPLYING FOR ALL STATE AND
FEDERAL FINANCIALLY IF THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE. FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN STUDENT SUPPORT
INTERVENTION. FOR THE PROGRAM
PROVIDES THE PAST HIGH SCHOOL I
REACH.
TUITION FREE EDUCATION FOR THE
FIRST YEAR AND SECOND.
PARDEE REGISTRATION ACCESS IS
IT'S NOT
.
RENTS AND SERVE AS AMBASSADORS
AND INTERNATIONAL IN RICHMOND
PROGRAM FUNDED AGAIN WITH
SUPPORT FROM THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
AND GENEROUS DONORS.
THIS PROGRAM OF THE LAST YEAR
HAS TAKEN COLLEGE PROMISE
STUDENTS TO EGYPT.
MAKO JAPAN AND THIS SUMMER WILL
BE SENDING PROMISE STUDENTS TO
FRANCE AND VIETNAM AS IN A
RICHMOND EXPERIENCE.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE NEVER
BEEN OUT OF THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
SO THIS PROVIDES A UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE FOR THEM INDEED.
AS IS YOUR WHERE MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE HOUSING FOOD AND
SECURE.
EFFORTS TO ASSISTANCE WITH
INCREASED FINANCIAL AID THAT
COVERS THEIR BASIC NEEDS WILL GO
A LONG WAY IN HELPING STUDENTS
TO FILL THEIR EDUCATIONAL.
POTENTIAL. FOUR STATES COMMITTEE
COLLEGES THE ABILITY TO TELL ALL
STUDENTS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT THE FIRST
YEAR.
OF TUITION IS FREE HAS ENABLED
US TO BREAK DOWN AXIS BEARS ARE
PREVENTED STUDENTS FROM
ATTEMPTING A COLLEGE EDUCATION
OR FOR A LIFETIME TO CAREER.
OR PROFESSION.
AS A RESULT THIS MESSAGE HAS
BEEN POWERFUL.
POWERFUL AN IMPROVING COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES CONSIDER THE RESULTS
OF LA IN ONLY TWO YEARS.
OVERLY ROMAN FOR RECENT LAUSD
GRADUATES HAS INCREASED BY 24%.
FULL TIME ENROLLMENT FOR FIRST
TIME COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM LAUSD
HAS INCREASED 54%.
DISTRICT WIDE IN FROM OUR FIRST
COURT OF LA COLLEGE PROMISE
STUDENTS MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
ARE READY TO TRANSFER INELIGIBLE
TO GRADUATE THIS SPRING.
AND THE POPULATIONS SERVED ARE
THOSE THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY
UNDER REPRESENTED YOU KNOW THE
STATISTICS AND THE DEMOGRAPHY OF
LOS ANGELES WELL FOR FROM THE
CLAIMS ARE FREE COLLEGE PROGRAM
SERVES.
THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD IT OUR
PROGRAM IS 72% BLACK NEXT. 82%
LOW INCOME BASED ON THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE GRANT
CRITERIA OUR INITIAL COURT HAS
SHOWN THESE DRAMATIC POSITIVE
OUTCOMES.
OVER 90% OF OUR STUDENTS
ATTEMPTED ENGLISH AND MATH WITH
MORE STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM
COMPLETING TRANSFER LEVEL OF
BOTH THEN WE HAD SEEN PREVIOUSLY
ACROSS THE AND TRY DISTRICT. 89%
OF FALL SEMESTER STUDENTS
PERSISTED THROUGH THE SPRING
SEMESTER. 76% FROM NOT SPRING
PERSISTED TO FALL MORE THAN
THREE OUT OF FOUR WITH OVER TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS CONTINUED ON
AS FULL TIME STUDENTS WHICH WE
KNOW IS THE KEY TO ACADEMIC
SUCCESS.
BROWN TRUCK THAT HUNDREDS OF
STUDENTS COMPLETE IN ONLY TWO
YEARS THIS SPRING I LOOK FORWARD
TO REPORTING THAT DATA IN THE
FALL.
THE BENEFITS OF AB NINETEEN AND
NOW AB TWO FUELS OUR ABILITY. TO
SUSTAIN OUR COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDE A COLLEGE EDUCATION TO
OUR STUDENTS AND TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE INVESTMENTS HAVE HAD A MAJOR
IMPACT WILL BE ON THE TUITION
THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE.
THE PROGRAM BUILDS A STRONG
FORWARD LOOKING COLLEGE GOING
CULTURE ONE THAT THROUGH
INCLUSION OF ALL.
IT HAS SERVE THOSE MOST IN NEED
AND BUILD THE STUDENT SUCCESS
PROGRAM THOSE PRISONERS PRODUCE
THESE WONDERFUL AND FOR US IN LA
UNPARALLELED OUTCOMES.
FINALLY IN CLOSING I WANT TO
MENTION THE MOUNTING SUPPORT AT
THIS PROGRAM HAS INSTILLED.
IN OUR COMMUNITY IT IS INDEED A
TALKING AND LEVERAGING POINT.
THE LA COLORS PROMISE PROGRAM IS
BROUGHT TOGETHER BUSINESS CIVIC
AND PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS IS
BUILT A MUTUAL SENSE OF
COMMITMENT FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
A MAY TWENTY NINE OVER PARTNERS
WILL JOIN US IN THE CELEBRATION
OF OUR FIRST ELLIE COLLEGE PROMS
GRADUATION POSTED BY MAYOR
CARCETTI. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MANY MORE THAT I CAN STATE LEC
CITY STRONGLY SUPPORTS EXPANDING
THIS PROGRAM FOR TWO YEARS OF
TUITION FREE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S SIMPLY THE BEST
INVESTMENT WE HAVE WITNESSED
FIRST HAND IN LOS ANGELES THE
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM FOR SECOND YEAR.
OUR STUDENTS HAVE TOLD US THAT A
SECOND YEAR FINANCIALLY SUPPORT
HAS ALLOWED THEM TO MAINTAIN
THEIR FULL TIME STATUS.
AND INDEED THERE ALTERNATE
SUCCESS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IN AB TWO WOULD ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE.
THIS COMMITMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS
SO THAT THEY TOO CAN COMPLETE
THE PROMISE AND ACHIEVE.
THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME AND
HAVE IT ANSWERED QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CANCER WILL COME BACK%
TO YOU -- IN A IN A MOMENT --
PRESIDENT THE FRANCO.
GREAT CHERRY MCCARTY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS JEFF TO FRANCO
I'M SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT FOR
LIKE TALK ME COLLEGE DISTRICT.
IT'S GOOD THAT WERE UP HERE
WITHOUT LIGHTS ARE GOING TO BE
THE OPPOSITE END OF THE SPECTRUM
WE ARE CONSIDERED A SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITY AGE WE SERVE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND FTS.
IN SOUTH LAKE TAHOE COMMUNITY --
BUT GIVE ME A SENSE OF MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE HIGH NEED ABOUT
36% OF THEM ARE FIRST GENERATION
AT THIS TIME.
IN COLLEGE PROMISES BEEN VERY
TRANSFORMATIVE FROCK CAMPUS IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PAST SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA ME
COLLEGES AND SPECIFICALLY THIS
PROGRAM IT'S BEEN A CATALYST
THAT OUR CAMPUS LA IN MANY
OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I HAVE THREE MAJOR POINTS IT
ONTO MY PRESENTATION I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOUR CURRENT PROGRAM
AND HOW IT'S MADE POSSIBLE FREE
BE.
NINETEEN OUR FUTURE EXPANSION
AND WHAT THE STATE COULD DO TO
SUPPORT IT AND FINALLY SOME OF
THE RESEARCH ON COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAMS NATIONALLY AND HOW WE
COMPARED ORGAN TENNESSEE AND
OTHER STATES.
THAT ARE LEADING THE WAY ALONG
WITH CALIFORNIA.
SO THE LATE TALK BECAUSE PROMISE
WAS ACTUALLY LAUNCHED IN FALL OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING TO OUR FOUNDATION ABOUT
GETTING BEHIND THIS INITIATIVE
IT WAS ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
THAT ALLOWED US TO YOU. TO MOVE
IT CREATED THAT CALLOUS MOMENT
TO MOVE TO GO FORWARD.
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING TUITION
WAIVERS FOR OUR FIRST TIME FULL
TIME STUDENTS WE A BRAIDED OUR
STATE FUNDS WITH LOCAL FUNDS TO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION FOR ALL
OUR STUDENTS TO FREE BUS PASSES.
SO YOU GET TO AND FROM WORK AND
SCHOOL IN ADDITIONALLY INFUSE
OUR LENDING LIBRARY SO STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS THE CHECKOUT
TEXTBOOKS FOR THEIR ACADEMIC
TERM TO NOT HAVE TO BUY THOSE
AND OF COURSE WE COUPLE THAT
WITH OUR OPEN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCE -- EFFORTS IN OUR
FOUNDATIONS TAKEN MORE OF ITS
LOCAL FUNDS IN TRIPLED ITS
EMERGENCY BOOK FUND FOR STUDENTS
THAT CAN'T MEET THEIR BOOK NEEDS
TO THOSE OTHER.
THIS OTHER MECHANISMS.
SO OUR PROGRAM NOT ONLY HAS
EXPANDED THAT TUITION WAIVERS
WERE PROVIDED EVERY OTHER
SUPPORT CENTER CRITICAL FOR ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS SPECIFIC.
BUT SPECIFICALLY MANY OF OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THAT ONLY
TRADITIONALLY BENEFITTED FOR THE
WHAT WAS KNOWN AS THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FEE WAIVER.
WE HAVE SOME PRELIMINARY RESULTS
TO SHARE THIS FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OUR FIRST TIME FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT IS UP 10% YEAR
OVER YEAR AND SELL COLLEGE
PROMISES CLEARLY MEETING ITS
GOAL AS BEING AN ACCESS
INITIATIVE.
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY THE STUDENTS
ACTUALLY WITH A QUALIFIED UNDER
WHAT WAS FORMALLY KNOWN AS A
BOARD OF GOVERNORS FEW EVER.
BUT IT'S THE SIMPLIFIED MESSAGE
OF FIRST TIME FULL TIME TUITION
FREE THAT IS UNDERSTOOD BY OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SPECIFICALLY MANY OF OUR FIRST
GENERATIONS FAMILIES.
I THINK THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
POINT TO MAKE HAS MANY TIMES
FOLKS SAY THIS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TO YOU ARE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET JUST GONNA
BENEFIT -- SINCE THEY DO NOT
HAVE NEEDS BUT OUR ABILITY TO
SAY FIRST TIME FULL TIME TUITION
FREE REALLY CLARIFIES THAT THE
DOORS ARE OPEN TO ALL STUDENTS
AND THAT'S THE MESSAGE IT'S
EASILY UNDER SAID.
SO WHERE WE GOING FROM HERE.
WE ARE WITH THE SUPPORT OF AARCS
FOUNDATION DOING A THREE YEAR ON
RAMP TO EXPAND STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES BEYOND TUITION WAIVERS
BUT DURING THOSE THREE YEARS.
IN ADDITION THE LANDING IRAN BUS
PASSES THAT THEY WILL GET BOOKS
STATEMENTS EACH TERM AS A
PERSISTS SO IT'S BASICALLY A
CARROT HELP SINCE THE MOVEMENT
PROCESS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
AXIS ISN'T SIMPLY ENOUGH.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE THIS
FROM AN ACCESS PROGRAM TO
ACTUALLY COMPLETION PROGRAM
WHICH IS VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH
THE STATE'S -- PROGRAMS AND
PRIORITIES.
I COULD SHARE WITH YOU.
THAT IT IS THE STATE WHO IS HELP
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THAT'S THE STATE HAS FUND IN ONE
YEAR AND HOPEFULLY WILL EXPAND
TO TWO YEARS HERE.
IT ALLOWS ME TO GO TO MY LOCAL
FOUNDATION AND ASK THEM TO RE
DIRECTOR FUNDS FOR ALL THESE
RAPPER AND SUPPORT STUDENT
SERVICES.
SUCH AS BOOKS AND TRANSPORTATION
AS WELL AS MONIES LOCAL MONIES
FOR PEER MENTORING AND DEDICATED
CANCER FOR PROMISE STUDENTS THAT
WE KNOW THESE THINGS IS
REFERENCE SERVICES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR COMPLETION. TO
GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE THE CURRENT
NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR THREE YOUR
COMPLETION IS 22% FOR THE SECOND
COHORT.
AT CITY UNIVERSITY NEW YORK ME
COLLEGES THEY'RE SEEN CRATER
THAN 50% COMPLETION FOR THREE
YEAR -- STUDENTS THROUGH
PROVIDING THESE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES WE CAN LEARN FROM THAT
IN BY THE STATE SUPPORT FOR
TUITION WAIVERS.
COUPLE THAT WITH LOCAL MONIES TO
PROVIDE THIS ADDITIONAL
REFERENCE SERVICES.
SO FINALLY I SHOULD WITH YOU TO
HEAR TODAY OF POLICY BRIEF THAT
I PUT TOGETHER THAT REALLY IT
TAKES A LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
OUT THERE NATIONWIDE AND WE ALL
KNOW SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WITH
WORKFORCE RAID READINESS.
STUDENT DAT -- ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THOSE ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED BUT LOOKING AT
TENNESSEE FOR AGAIN NEW YORK
THESE OTHER THESE OTHER STATES
ARE TAKING ONLY ON STATE WHERE
PROGRAMS -- WE ARE THERE ALONG A
LONGER SIDE BUT I THINK
CALIFORNIA HAS A CHANCE HERE TO
BE A LEADER AGAIN AS WE OFTEN
HAD.
AND NOT JUST MAKE THIS ABOUT A
ONE YEAR ACCESS INITIATIVE BUT
MOVE FROM ACCESS TO COMPLETION
BY PROVIDING MULTIPLE YEARS.
OF TUITION WAIVERS FOR STUDENTS
SO NOT ONLY CAN THEY GET IN THE
DOOR BUT THEY CAN ACTUALLY GET
GET ACROSS THE STAGE IN MOVE ON
TO BE CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY SO.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK
MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
I WOULD SAY I THINK TWO YEARS IS
THE NEXT STEP I THINK HERE'S THE
NEXT STEP WHICH IS A GOOD
ALIGNMENT WITH YOUR GUIDED
PATHWAYS INITIATIVE IN YOUR
FOCUS ON COMPLETION.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT SUPPORTING --
ASSEMBLY BILL TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET.
METHODS TO MAKE PROGRESS TOWARD
THAT SECOND YEAR I COULD TELL
YOU LOCALLY WE'RE GONNA
PROVIDING THREE YEARS OF
FOUNDATION SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
FOR THE BOOK VOUCHERS IN THOSE
OTHER MECHANISMS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SOMETIMES
IT TAKES SINCE MORE THAN TWO
YEARS TO GET TO GET THROUGH THE
PAST SO -- I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND STAND READY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MR GREEN.
HI THANK YOU ARE LOW YES ARE YOU.
VERY WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION JIM MCCARTHY AND AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'VE
GOT SOMETHING I THINK IS BEING
PASSED AROUND RIGHT NOW -- SO MY
NAME'S JEFF GREEN ON THE CEO OF
THE SANTA BARBARA CITY COLLEGE
FOUNDATION.
AND WE'RE COMING AT THIS AS A AS
A COLLEGE THAT ACTUALLY LAUNCHED
A PROMISE -- JUST PRIOR TO THE
IS REALLY AT THE EARLY PART OF
THE WAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO I
THOUGHT I COULD SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT WE'VE LEARNED --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I HAD A
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH THE
GERMAN MCCARTY -- LAST FALL --
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MOAN AND AND THIS IS -- REALLY
AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO DO I WILL SKIP THROUGH --
SOME THE OVERVIEW AND AND YOU
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT WELL BUT
BUT WHAT WE TRIED TO DO IN IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE REALLY SET OUT
TO SEE WHAT A MODEL PROMISE
MIGHT LOOK LIKE IN THIS WAS AT A
TIME WHEN THERE WERE ONLY THREE
PROMISE EFFORTS IN.
THE STATE -- THOSE WERE OF
COURSE VENTURA FIRST -- THEN
LONG BEACH AND THEN ON TO QUEST
OUR NEIGHBOR TO THE NORTH SO
WHAT WE DID IS WE'VE SURVEYED
ABOUT -- THIRTY PROGRAMS AROUND
THE COUNTRY THE TIME TO ASK WHAT
REALLY WORKED BEST AND IF IF
RESOURCES WEREN'T THE BARRIER
WHAT WOULD BE POSSIBLE -- THE
WAY THEY THEY ALL CAME BACK WITH
THEIR RESPONSES WAS WAS --
UNANIMOUS ESSENTIALLY THAT THAT
IF THEY WEREN'T THE IF THEY
WEREN'T CONSTRAINED BY RESOURCES
THEY WOULD DO TO FOR YEARS ALL
INCLUSIVE AN OPEN ACCESS TO THE
ENTIRETY OF THE THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
SO THAT'S HOW WE SET OUT TO DO --
AND WE MADE OUR ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS VERY BROAD
INTENTIONALLY -- WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT LATER IF THERE'S AN
INTEREST -- BUT YOU CAN SEE HERE
THE THE SCOPE AND DESIGN WAS
BASICALLY BASED ON OUR RESEARCH
AND THERE ARE THREE PRIMARY
COLORS TO THAT THE FIRST WAS
COMPLETELY OPEN ACCESS TO ALL
LOCAL STUDENTS -- AND THAT WAS
REGARDLESS OF OF PERFORMANCE IN
HIGH SCHOOL REGARDLESS OF
DEMONSTRATED NEED OR NOT BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S COURSE NEED IT'S OFTEN
NOT.
CLEAR -- WHEN WHEN PUT TO PAPER
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE OFFER THAT
WE PRICED IT OUT -- AND WE CAME
UP WITH ABOUT A TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
EXPENDITURE TO DO THIS FOR OUR
STUDENTS IN OUR DISTRICT AND AS
OF TODAY IT'S ACTUALLY ABOUT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS THAT
ARE RECEIVING THIS. TO SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS COMING FROM
WITHIN OUR AT STCC DISTRICTS OF
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT
WHICH ENCOMPASSES TWO LARGE
PUBLIC DISTRICTS AND IN EVERY
MANNER OF PRIVATE HOME SCHOOL --
EVERY COMPLETION YOU CAN THINK
OF THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
INCLUDING SO IT'S REALLY BROAD
BASED -- WE DID ABOUT A HUNDRED
INTERVIEWS IN THE COMMUNITY TO
TO FIGURE OUT -- WHAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTED AND AND CAME BACK WITH
WITH THE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FOR
THIS SO?
IN THE END WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE IS IS CHAU -- GATHER THE
DATA THAT WILL SHOW THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON STUDENT SUCCESS
STUDENT PERSISTENCE TO
COMPLETION AND YOU CAN SEE HERE
IN WHAT I'VE HANDED YOU.
A LITTLE BIT OF THAT DATA -- THE
FIRST COUPLE ARE ARE JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE LOW THE
STUDENTS CARRY WE REQUIRED THE
THREE THINGS THAT THE RESEARCH
ALL AGREED ON FULL TIME STUDENT
STATUS -- WE KNOW THERE'S A
COURSE THE COMPLICATION OF THAT
BECAUSE THERE SOME STUDENTS WERE
THAT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE -- ALSO
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OUR
COMMUNITY WELL THE VARIOUS TYPES
OF OF COUNSELING ON ON CAMPUS --
CAN BE COHORT STYLE CAN BE WITH
OUR GENERAL COUNSEL DEPARTMENT
AND THEN WE HAVE TO HAVE
STUDENTS ACTUALLY BUT YOU GET
WITHIN A YEAR SO WE HAVE ABOUT A
YEAR'S WINDOW FROM THE HIGH
SCHOOL COMPLETION.
WHEN THAT WAS ALL SAID AND DONE
YOU CAN SEE HERE ARE COMPLETION
AND PERSISTENCE RATES UP TO DATE
NOW ARE ONLY IN OUR THIRTY YEARS
SO WE ONLY HAVE ONE COHORT
THAT'S MADE IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH?
BUT WHAT WE CAN SHOW IS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO TO REALLY
BOOST THE PERSISTENCE RATES IN
THOSE FIRST FEW SEMESTERS SO
THIS IS GOING BACK JUST TO THE
FALL OF TWENTY SIXTEEN NOW WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ABOUT 85%
ASSISTANCE RATE. FOR THAT FIRST
TO SECOND SEMESTER -- WHICH IS
THE BENCHMARK THAT WE'RE NOW
WORKING WITH EVERYTHING ELSE ON
THE SECOND THIRD -- COHORTS OR
SOME MORE DATA HERE ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE STUDYING BUT I THINK THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE -- GO ARE THESE
LAST TWO GRAPHS IF YOU YOU LOOK
AT FULL TIME STATUS FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS.
AND WHAT YOU'LL SEE THE BAR
GRAPH -- GIVE THE DETAILS BUT
THAT THAT FULL TIME STATUS LINE
GRAPH -- IT BASICALLY INVERTS SO
BY REQUIRING IN SUPPORTING FULL
TIME STUDENT STATUS WHAT WE HAVE
IS GOING FROM A TWO TO ONE TO A
ONE TO TWO RATIO AS FAR AS WHAT
OUR LOCAL STUDENTS DOING SO
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY THE THE
PROBABLY MOST POWERFUL DATA
POINT WE HAVE TODAY.
WHICH IS THAT BY INCENTIVIZING
AND REMOVING SOME OF THESE
BARRIERS THAT'S ACTUALLY WORKING --
IN IT NOW WE'RE JUST IN OUR
THIRTY YEARS SO WE KNOW THAT
WE'LL SEE SOME VARIATION THERE
BUT THAT'S THAT'S REALLY THE
FIRST.
AND THEN TO MOVE ON TO THE
DOLLAR SIDE OF IT WHICH OF
COURSE IS WHAT WE'RE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT LAST BLOCK GRAPH YOU I
WOULD TRY TO SHOW YOU BY
STACKING THE VARIOUS FORMS OF
SUPPORT WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW.
IN OUR CASE WE STARTED THIS
EXCLUSIVELY WITH PRIVATE
FUNDRAISING ALSO JUST
PHILANTHROPY -- AND THEN WITH
THE REBRAND OF THE BOG WAIVER
AND THEN THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE --
THERE'S MORE PIECES TO THE
PUZZLE BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
STACK WHAT IT SHOWS THERE IS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
GRANTS.
ACTUALLY COVERS ABOUT A LITTLE
OVER A THIRD.
OF OF THE TOTAL COST OF WHAT
WE'RE OFFERING -- AND SO WE
THINK THAT THAT IS OF COURSE THE
FOUNDATION THAT'S THE LONGEST
STANDING OFFER AND THAT IS THE
BASELINE OF SUPPORT -- YOU THEN
SEE THERE THAT -- WE WE COVER
THE THE ROMAN FEES FOR THE
REMAINDER AND THEN THE LARGEST
PIECE OF THIS AND AGAIN THIS IS
ANOTHER DEMONSTRATION OF THAT
I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN.
IS THAT IT'S ACTUALLY THE BOOKS
SUPPLIES AND EVERYTHING ELSE --
THAT IS THE GREATER BARRIER AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SHOULD WE'RE
COVERING EXCLUSIVELY WITH
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS.
OF COURSE IF WE COULD WE WOULD
GO BEYOND THAT AN OFFER OTHER --
FULL COST KIND OF SUPPORT THAT
RIGHT AT THIS POINT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE OFFERING.
ON AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
THE BIG THINGS ARE GRAPPLING
WITH NOW AND AND I THINK THE
THINGS THAT ARE -- THEY'RE GOING
TO GRAPPLE WITH OBVIOUSLY IN THE
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS ARE HARD
TO PRIMARILY ONE IS THE
MESSAGING AROUND THAT SO -- FOR
THOSE OF US THAT ARE RAISING
DOLLARS PHILANTHROPIC LEE AND
CALLING IT A COLLEGE PROMISE AND
OF COURSE THAT'S THE HISTORY
GOING BACK TO TWO THOUSAND FIVE
IN KALAMAZOO MICHIGAN -- WHEN
ADDITIONAL THINGS BRANDED AS
COLLEGE PROMISE ENTER THE
PLAYING FIELD WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT OUR MESSAGING FOR MESSAGING
HAS TO GET CLEAR -- AND THAT'S
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE WERE
HAVING RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
PRIVATE BASIS SUPPORT SO WE
DON'T WANT TO GIVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT THERE IT'S IT'S
OVER WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
PROMISE ANYMORE.
I'M IN FACT WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
THE STATE IS CONTINUING TO
ASSESS STEP UP AND AND AND OFFER
NEW SOURCES OF SUPPORT AND THIS
COR PRIVATELY FUNDED PROMISE IS
STILL -- WHAT WE'RE ASKING OUR
COMMUNITY TO DO SO THAT IS A
WITH IN OUR COMMUNITY THE OTHER
PIECES OF COURSE THE BRANDING
AROUND THE COLLEGE IS IT IS IT
FREE COLLEGE IS A FULL SUPPORT
IS A TOTAL COSTS ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGIES GET VERY
CONFUSING TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
WHEN?
THEY'RE TRYING TO SUPPORT THIS --
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS FIND WAYS TO INTRODUCE THIS
AS THIS IS WHAT OUR COMMUNITY
OFFERS THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC
MEANS -- THIS IS WHAT THE STATE
IS OFFERING -- WE OFTEN LEAD
WITH THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP HAS DONE THE BEST IN
THE ENTIRE NATION ABOUT KEEPING
FEES LOW WHEN IT COMES TO TO RUN
MOMENT FEES.
ON AND STILL FOR MANY STUDENTS
THAT IS A BARRIER AND THE BIGGER
BARRIERS ACTUALLY EVERYTHING
ELSE AND SO IT'S THE EVERYTHING
ELSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE TALK
ABOUT COLLEGE PROMISE -- IN OUR
REGION -- WE ARE LOOKING AT A
FEW OTHER THINGS WHICH I THINK
IN THAT IN THE COMING YEARS WHAT
WILL GET.
A BETTER HANDLE ON WE WE'RE
LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS
THE AB NINETEEN FUNDS -- AND YOU
SEEN IN YOUR REPORT THAT THE THE
THE INCREDIBLE VARIETY OF HOW
DISTRICTS ARE USING THOSE -- IS
BOTH A BLESSING AND A BIG
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE CAN'T
MESSAGE THAT ACROSS THE STATE IN
A SINGLE WAY -- AND THERE'S NO
THERE IS NO SINGLE EXPLANATION
FOR WHAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE GOING
TO WE'RE TRYING TO SAY IS HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING LOCALLY HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT -- AND OF
COURSE -- IF WE SEE AB TWO MONEY
COMING THROUGH THEN THAT WILL
HAVE THAT SAME CONVERSATION
AGAIN SO THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
WHERE WE'RE AT OKAY.
THANK YOU.
UP I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS BUT
LOOKS LIKE OVER HERE FIRST OF
WOMEN REALLY MONTHS GREAT THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
PRESENTING PARTICULARLY FROM
THOSE THAT FROM THE DISTRICT
JEFF THANKS FOR COMING.
I'M I'M LOOKING AT YOUR THE
BLOCK.
THE THE BLOCK AT RAF HERE AND SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS FOR ALL SCHOOLS
IS THIS.
SIMILAR BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
THIS THE CALIFORNIA PROMISED
GRANT IS ABOUT.
LITTLE UNDER 40% IF I READ IT
RIGHT A LITTLE UNDER 40% OF THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE
WE REALLY TALKED ABOUT THE TOTAL
COST OF A TELL ATTENDANCE BUT I
WORK WITH COLLEGE STUDENTS WE
DIDN'T JUST TALK ABOUT THE COST
OF TUITION.
IS THAT SIMILAR FOR ALL
DISTRICTS WHERE IT'S SLIGHTLY
UNDER 40% THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S FREE COLLEGE
DOES IT PAYS.
FOR THAT WERE DOES THAT PERCENT.
VERY BASED ON REGION.
I DON'T I EIGHT YEAH IF YOU CAN
ALL SPEAK TO THAT ANYTHING IS
THAT RIGHT YEAH I'M IS CERTAINLY
VERY IS ON RE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THE HOUSING COSTS IS THE IS THE
GREAT VARIABLE THIS BLOCK THEY
THIS GRAPH HERE DOES NOT SHOW
THAT SERVICE IS.
ONLY BE HARD COST OF ATTENDANCE
SO THIS IS NOT SHOWING -- FOOD
HOUSING ANYTHING ELSE THIS IS
JUST THE THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
BOOKS SUPPLIES FEES IN OUR CASE
THE THE GREATER VARIABLE HERE IS --
CERTAIN CD PROGRAM SAY --
CULINARY OR MARINE DIVING TACTIC
AND HAVE MUCH HIGHER SUPPLY
ANOTHER REQUIREMENT COSTS AND
THEN SAY AND AND ENGLISH
ASSOCIATES WHICH IS GOING TO BE
A SMALLER CASA THAT'S ACTUALLY
GREATER VARIANCE IT'S AVERAGED
INTO THIS BLOCK IT DOES NOT
COUNT FOR OTHER COSTS.
IN THIS LIMóN I WOULD SIMPLY
ADD THAT ARE FACTORED THE NUMBER
THAT WE USE IS EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
FOR FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
AT A COMMITTEE COLLEGE IN LOS
ANGELES.
SO OF THAT OF THE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND IF THAT'S THE FULL COST
OF ATTENDANCE WHAT DOES THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE ACTUALLY PAY
FOR WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THAT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT DOESN'T PAY FOR
ALL EIGHTEEN DOWN -- IT'S 829%.
IT PAYS 4829% OF THE CORRECT
THEM BECAUSE THIS THIRTEEN UNDER
EIGHTY DOLLARS.
IS IT TOO IS THE FEE WAIVER OUR
THE FLUFFY.
EIGHTEEN OUR AND THEN IT WAS
JUST.
SIMILAR I'M I THINK THOSE
PERCENTAGES ARE VERY
ILLUSTRATIVE OF WHAT YOU'D SEE
UP IN IN THE STATE AND THAT THE
TUITION FEE WAIVER IT'S A HURDLE
BUT IT'S ONLY ONE OF THE HURDLES
AND I THINK.
ASISTIR MEAN THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MOVEMENT LOOKING AT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ASSEMBLY
BILL -- TO THERE'S ALSO SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY ONE THAT'S BEING
SPENT ON THE OTHER SIDE ABOUT.
THE MOON THE EXPANSIVE NEEDS AND
SUPPORTS OUR NEEDS INDUSTRY FOR
OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND SO
IT'S NOT ONE POLICY THAT'S GOING
TO SOLVE ALL THIS BUT I THINK
PROMISES A VERY IMPORTANT STEP
BECAUSE IT REMOVES A BARRIER
TUITION AND IT SIMPLIFIES THE
THE MESSAGE TO FAMILIES IN
INCOMING.
STUDENTS IN THIS POINT
OUTSOURCING BEAUTIFULLY FROM THE
SANTA BARBARA EXAMPLE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE.
THE COLLEGE PROMISE FOR THE
TREMENDOUS CIVIC AND
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT.
US SO THAT THEY CAN.
THE RALLY AROUND THE NOTION THAT
EVERY PERSON IN THE COMMUNITY TO
GO TO COLLEGE SO THAT'S WHAT
MANY WORK UNITS HAVE DONE IT'S A
LEVERAGE POINT IT CERTAINLY IS.
GREAT AND NOW THE SECOND HER IS
IT THERE HAVE BEEN.
YOU KNOW SEND SOME DESCRIPTIONS
OF KIND OF HOW WE CAN ENHANCE
WHETHER IT'S THE MESSAGING OR
THE WORK AND YOU'RE IN FRONT OF
ALL OF US NOW COULD YOU PROVIDE
SUGGESTIONS I MEAN IT'S JUST
BEEN IDENTIFIED THAT.
THERE COULD BE WAYS TO LEVERAGE
MORE IF WE MESSAGE DAY IN A
DIFFERENT WAY IF WE'VE PARTNERED
IN A DIFFERENT WAY WHAT WITH
THOSE SUGGESTIONS LOOK LIKE.
YEAH I I MEAN I I WOULD SAY THAT
THE DEAD PARSING OUT THE TYPES
OF BARRIERS THE TYPES OF COSTS
IS USEFUL AND I UNDERSTAND THE
SIMPLICITY OF A FREE COLLEGE
MESSAGING -- BUT IT'S ACTUALLY A
DISSERVICE IN THE LONG RUN
BECAUSE IT IT GIVES PEOPLE --
THE IT BAKERIES ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT WHAT IS AND WHAT IS NOT
COVERED -- AND AND HISTORICALLY
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE WAY COLLEGES
TALKED ABOUT WE'RE TALKING
TYPICALLY ABOUT THE TUITION AND
FEE OR MAYBE ROOM AND BOARD IF
YOU'RE TALK ABOUT RESIDENTIAL
FOUR YEAR -- AND SO THIS WAY OF
TALKING ABOUT COLLEGE ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REALLY
RELATIVELY NEW ESPECIALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
COLLEGES WHO WHO REMEMBER IT
DIFFERENTLY TALK ABOUT IT THINK
ABOUT IT DIFFERENTLY SO IT'S
REALLY A RETRAINING OF TOTAL
COSTS.
MEANS AND THEN WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THE HOUSING.
THE FOOD SECURITY AND OF COURSE
TUITION BOOKS AND IF YOU
ACTUALLY TEAR THAT -- THAT THE
MOST USEFUL THING I'VE SEEN ON
THAT AND AND I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUES OF CFC THIS IS THE IS
TEDIOUS RESEARCH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
AND WHAT THEY DID IS THEY
COMPILED ALL TOOK.
ALL IN COSTS OF THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE AND THEN BACKED
OUT OF PRO RATA SHARE OF WHAT
FINANCIALLY GRANTED NOT NOT THAT
IS AVAILABLE -- AND WHAT THEY
DID IS ESSENTIALLY INVERTED THAT
THAT HIGHER BECAUSE OF THE
ASSUMPTION THAT A FOUR YEAR YOU
YOU SEE.
IS ACTIVE THE MOST EXPENSIVE IT
ACTUALLY INVERTS IN MOST REGIONS
WHERE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
THE MOST EXPENSIVE BECAUSE SO
LITTLE GRANT EIGHT IS AVAILABLE
SO IN THAT IN THAT CONTEXT THIS
BECOMES A REALLY VALUABLE TOOL
AND AND THE LEVERAGING AND
EVERYTHING YOU CAN DO AROUND IT --
SO THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
MESSAGING WE TENDED TO GO.
FOR I MISSED THE ONE I WOULD ADD
THAT.
STILL TO THIS DAY THERE ARE
STILL MANY COMMUNITIES FAMILIES
WHO STILL BELIEVE.
THAT A HIGHER EDUCATION EVEN THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE EDUCATION.
IS STILL OUT OF REACH FOR
EXAMPLE THIS FALL 57%.
OF ALL OF OUR NEW ATTENDEES WERE
FIRST GENERATION IN LOS ANGELES
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT ALMOST SIX OUT OF TEN
SO THEY'RE STILL NEW ENTRIES SO
WE STILL NEED TO COMMUNICATE.
THE BENEFITS OF AND OF OF A
HIGHER EDUCATION TO GOAL LOCAL
TO GO LOW COST.
AND REALLY TO EXTEND THE LARGER
MESSAGE WHICH WE ALL KNOW.
THAT EDUCATED CITIZENRY IS THE
WAY TO GO IT IS FIELD
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC STRAIGHT
FOR DECADES.
OF STARTING -- IF YOU WILL WITH
THAT IN NINETEEN SIXTY WITH THE
PROLIFERATION OF COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES AND INVESTED IN ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THIS HUMAN CAPITAL
SO IT'S THE SAME SORT OF
MESSAGING NOW THAT WE NEED ALL
PERSONS.
IN CALIFORNIA TO BE OF
RESPONSIVE ELIGIBLE FOR AND AND
ACCOMMODATED THAT AND THEN IN
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
ARE THE PLACE TO DO THAT WE
STILL ARE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
FULFILL THE BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
GAP THAT IS NEEDED TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA.
A COMPETITIVE A FEW WELL -- THE
INVESTMENT THAT IS MAY HAVE YOUR
KITCHEN IS BY FAR.
THE BEST INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA
COULD MAKE.
WITH RESPECT TO INVEST IN AS
PEOPLE IT THE ALLEVIATES OTHER
KINDS OF IT OF IF WE WILL.
SOCIAL SERVICE SUPPORTS AND
OTHER THINGS IF WE DON'T EDUCATE
FOLKS THE COSTS ARE TOO HIGH SO
THE MESSAGING NEEDS TO BE AROUND
THE NEED FOR BENEFITS OF AND WHY
IT MATTERS.
IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES SINCE WE
HAVE A MULTI LINGUAL -- STATE
BEAUTIFULLY A MULTI LEVEL STATE.
AND I WAS BRIEFLY ADD TO TO
MESSAGING THE CONSIDERATIONS.
I THINK WANT ONE THING THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT AS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GO TO OUR DONORS AT THIS
POINT AND SAYING THIS THE STATE
HAVE SKIN IN THIS GAME BUT BUT
WE NEED MORE.
TO FINISH THE PUZZLE RIGHT IN
TERMS OF THIS TOTAL COSTS OF
ATTENDANCE IN SO I THINK THAT
THE MORE THE STATE CAN CONTINUE
TO DO IT ALLOWS US TO GO BACK TO
THE SAME DONORS AND SAVE.
THE STATE'S NOW DO YOU KNOW
ADDED THE SECOND YEAR FOR
TUITION WE NEED YOUR HELP TO ADD
A SECOND YOU'RE FOR BOOKS SO I I
THINK THAT'S ONE THING THAT THAT
HOPE YOU'RE CONSIDERING --
CERTAINLY IF YOU WANT ONE
MESSAGING THING AND I HAVE A
SOLUTION ON THIS BUT YOU'LL
NOTICE WE CONSISTENT REFER TO
THE BORDER GOVERNOR SKI WAIVER
EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE GRANT FOR
NUMBER YEARS.
AND THAT'S CREATED A LITTLE
CONFUSION THE MARKET PLACE OUT
THERE BECAUSE WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA PROMISE
WHICH IS FIRST TIME FULL TIME
TUITION FREE AND WE KNOW WE WILL
THAT SINCE YOU START FULL TIME
INCOMPLETE.
THOSE UNITS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
SUCCEED IN COMPLETE ON TIME --
BUT THEN THERE'S THIS OTHER
PROMISE GRANT THAT'S OUT THERE --
SO THAT THAT HAS CREATED SOME
CONFUSION WITH OUR AS SOON
POPULATIONS ARE FAMILIES -- EVEN
WITH ARE CANCELING STAFF AND SO
THAT SOMETHING AS A STATE AT
SOME POINT WE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER HOW TO DIFFERENTIATE
THOSE PROGRAMS -- MORE CLEARLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES I CAN APPLES ON APPLE.
I WELL WOULD BE I'M NOT SURE
WHERE WE NEED THE SAME THING
TWICE BUT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL.
BUT BUT I I DID WANT TO MENTION
ELEMENT MISTER GALLAGHER HAD HAS
THAT'S COMMENTS HERE JUST REAL
QUICK WE JUST HAD A EVENT
OUTSIDE WITH THE CSU STUDENTS
AND THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW.
82% OF THEIR FOR YOU SO YOU SAID
IT'S 18%. FOR THREE EIGHTY FIRST
18% OF THE COST FOR TUITION SO
IT'S EIGHTEEN THOUSAND PER YEAR
HE SAID IT'S 18% REBEL OR NO
8829% 829% YES MUCH LOWER 829%
THE FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE YEAH
HE INCLUDE THE COST LIVING BOOKS.
AND OTHER COSTS OF ATTENDANCE
THE TUITION PART IS OVER 90% OF
THE COST OF COMMUNICABLE JUST
NON PRESCRIPTION YEAH SO IT'S
CSU THE STATE'S WERE SAYING IT'S
ABOUT 80%.
STILL THAT THAT'S THAT THAT
THAT'S THE POINT HERE -- I'M
GONNA COME BACK YOU GUYS IN A
BIT BUT MISTER GALLAGHER.
YES -- IS GOING TO GET INTO TO
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY KIND OF DATA
OR BE TRACKED ANY DATA IS IN
TOWN OF ONLYHAD THIS FOR ONE
YEAR NOW BUT SHOWING THAT WE'VE
HAD.
YOU KNOW MORE STUDENTS THAN WE
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE -- AND AND
ALSO.
ON THAT SAME LINE OF THAT SAME
TRACK THAT YOU HAVE STUDENTS
WHO'VE COME IN RIGHT NOW UNDER
THE PROMISE.
PROGRAM FIRST YEAR WHO ARE.
SAYING THEY WOULD NOT GO FOR A
SECOND HERE BECAUSE THE THE FEE
THE FEES WOULD.
THEN BE REINSTATED YEAH.
WE WE HAVE SOME DATA SO WE OURS
GOES BACK THREE YEARS NOW SO THE
DATA WE DO HAVE SHOWS UR
INITIAL PROJECTION BASED ON OUR
ENROLLMENT -- SO FOR FOR EXAMPLE
IN OUR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT EIGHT HUNDRED WAS THAT
THE MEDIAN ENROLLMENT OVER THE
PRIOR FIVE YEARS.
EIGHT HUNDRED FIVE SO WE
PROJECTED OUR PROMISE
PARTICIPATION BASED ON THAT DATA
POINT ON WHAT WE DISCOVERED IS
THAT WHEN YOU OFFER AN
INCENTIVIZE AND BUILD A
STRUCTURE LIKE THIS -- YOU OUT
WE DIDN'T THINK THERE WAS MUCH
ROOM TO GO UP BECAUSE OUR OUR
CAPTURE EIGHT IN DISTRICT IS
ALREADY.
BASICALLY 50% -- AS IT TURNS OUT
THERE WAS THERE WAS ROOM SO
INSTEAD OF HAVING THIRTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN THE PROMISE
AT A TIME WHICH IS WHAT WE
PROJECTED WHERE AT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED WE LOOK AT THE OVERALL
ENROLLMENT THE SAME THING AND
ACTUALLY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GRAPHS AND THE IN.
THAT PRESENTATION YOU'LL
ACTUALLY SEE WE HAD TWO
SIMULTANEOUS TRENDS SO WE'VE HAD
FALLING ENROLLMENT FOR TEN YEARS
IN OUR DISTRICT -- BUT LOCAL
ENROLLMENT IS ACTUALLY LEVELED
OUT AND NOW BEGUN TO INCREASE OF
OUR OVERALL ENROLLMENT IS STILL
DROPPING -- AND IS A NUMBER OF
FACTORS WE BELIEVE FOR THAT --
INCLUDING OF THE PROLIFERATION
OF PROMISE EFFORTS KEEPING FOLKS
MORE LOCAL -- BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY
SEEING AN INCREASE OF A
CONSIDERABLE INCREASE CLOSE
2215% IN OUR LOCAL DISTRICT.
MISTER GELLER EFFECT ON AT ON
THE LOS ANGELES STORY.
IS ALSO A GOOD STORY WHILE
OVERALL THE ROMANS A LITTLE SOFT
IN THE OR STOP THE STATEWIDE WE
SOLVED OVERALL INCREASE.
OF 24% FROM OUR LA U. S. THE
STUDENT GRADUATES OVER TWO YEARS.
TO LACC THE AND THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT TO PUT THAT IN
NUMBERS WE HAD FOUR THOUSAND
SIXTY THREE STUDENTS PARTICIPATE
YEAR.
ONE THIS WAS BEFORE AB NINETEEN
WAS ENACTED IN WITH AB NINETEEN
AT FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED IN THE
SECOND YEAR AND WE'RE MOVING
TOWARDS.
TEN THOUSAND BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS OF THE
ANSWER IS YES.
WITH THESE STUDENTS HAVE
OTHERWISE COME WELL WE'RE IN.
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT COLLEGE GOING RATE IS
60%.
PUT IT IN DIFFERENT TERMS 40% OF
LA U. S. THE STUDENTS TO NOT GO
TO COLLEGE.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS US AN
INTERVENTION TO INCREASE THE
COLLEGE GOING RATE THE STUDENTS
WHO COULD BENEFIT BY IT THE THE
MOST.
WITH THE STUDENTS HAVE NORMALLY
COME YEAR ONE YEAR TO WILL THE
PERSISTENCE RATES.
THAT I SHARED WERE SIGNIFICANT
OVER 90% FROM FALL TO SPRING AND
THEN 76% FROM SPRING TO FALL
DOES MOMENTUM POINTS THAT
STUDENTS GAIN.
ACADEMIC CONFIDENCE KING COURSES
AND TAKE ENGLISH AND MATH IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR EMISSIONS MAP
HAS PROVEN TO BE EITHER A
GATEKEEPER OR A GATEWAY.
IT'S A COMPLETION SO THE
STUDENTS TAKING THIS COURSE IS
THE FIRST YEAR THE HIGHER
PERSISTENCE RATES SUGGEST THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS WORKING AND IT'S
WORKING FOR THE MOST
ACADEMICALLY AND LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS THAT ARE COMMITTEES OUT.
IS THAT 40%.
ARE WE INCLUDING AND THAT WHAT
ABOUT FOLKS AND I GO TO A
TECHNICAL TRAINING PROGRAM. 60%
ANY FORM POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION TO ANY TWO YEAR ENDED
IN ALL OF YOU KNOW NOT JUST
GONNA NOT COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT
ANY KIND OF LIKE CT OR OTHER
TYPE THAT'S OVER THAT'S
CORRECTIVE 60% OF LA USED TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL SOMEWHERE.
POST SECONDARY 40% DO NOT ENROLL
IN ANY POST SECONDARY
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S A VERY HIGH
RATE OF THE THIRTY TWO OR SO.
THOUSAND DAILY WAS THE HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR SO THAT'S SO THIS
PROGRAM IS A ALLOWING US TO
AMELIORATE.
THAT ISSUE THAT'S WHY ELLIE U.
S. THESE IN SUCH A VERY VERY
COMMITTED IN STRONG PART IN THE
SEPARATE WITH CHANGING THE LIVES
OF FAMILIES BY ALLOWING THEM TO
GO. TO COLLEGE TUITION FREE YEAH
SO EVEN THOUGH IT'S KIND OF A
MISNOMER BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
TUITION IT'S YOUR POINTS 90%.
OF COLLEGE IS NOT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TUITION BUT IT'S A HOOK
IT'S FOR HER TO GET THE STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES YEAH BUT DO
YOU FEEL THAT'S A LITTLE BIT.
DECEITFUL BECAUSE THEY'RE
SHOWING UP NAY HEY WHERE'S THE
REST OF THE DAY WHERE'S THE REST
OF MY ADVANCE LAID TO PAY FOR
EVERYTHING NO SIR NOTHING JUST
ADD ON TO THAT BECAUSE I THINK
IS IS IS.
ALSO IF YOU CAN STAY LOCAL WHICH
YOU SEEN YOUR LOCAL ROMINGER MIA
MAYBE YOU CAN STAY WITH FAMILY
OR YOU CAN STATE YOU KNOW MAYBE
MAYBE IT IS MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SITUATION RATHER THAN
HAVING TO GO.
TO ANOTHER PLACE RIGHT AND AND
AND WERE HOUSING MIGHT BE MORE
EXPENSIVE IS THAT I MEAN WHAT IF
I COULD JUST ADD SOME INTO BOTH
YOUR COMMENTS -- IT DEFINITELY
IS A HOOK TO YOUR COMMENT ABOUT
WHAT OUR STUDENTS SAYING ABOUT
THE NEXT YEAR THAT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING WE'RE HEARING
ANECDOTALLY FROM STUDENTS --
OKAY I GOT AND I GOT THIS FIRST
YEAR WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO ME NOW
SOME OF THE SINCE WILL QUALIFY
BOARD GOVERNOR'S VIEW WAIVER WE
HAVE A SCHOLARSHIP AND SUPPORT
PROGRAMS ON CAMPUS.
BUT IT'S ENOUGH TO GET ME IN THE
DOOR IT'S A HOOK BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO REALLY GIVE ME A GOOD
CHANCE A COMPLETION AND SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE SECOND
YEAR.
IS SO KEY AND AS WE TRY AND
DRIVE DOWN TIME TO COMPLETION
MATCHING OUR FUNDING FOR PROMISE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH OUR TARGET FOR
THAT I THINK THERE'S GOOD
ALIGNMENT THERE WITH YOUR OTHER
INITIATIVES THAT USED TO ORDERED.
AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY ALONG WITH
THIS ONE SO.
I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK THE MORE THE STATE COULD
DO FOR TUITION AND FEES.
THE MORE WE COULD DO WITH OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND OUR
PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS TO
SUPPORT BOOKS -- AT A COST OF
ATTENDANCE TRANSPORTATION THINGS
OF THE SUCH BOEING'S RECORDED
YOU.
WHICH IS A IS A GOOD.
ONE AN IMPORTANT WHEN AND THAT
AS YOUR LOTUS IS PART OF THE
CRITERIA FOR COLLEGE PROMISE
PARTICIPATION STUDENTS MUST
APPLY FOR BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID WHICH ALLOWS THEM
TO RECEIVE ALL THE MAXIM
SUPPORTS.
OF THAT THEY NEED SO TECHNICALLY
THEY COULD RECEIVE NINE TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN AID AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW IF
THEY'RE FULLY ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
NOW UNFORTUNATELY ARE IN
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS ARE NOT OLDER
FOR FEDERAL AID SO WE LOOK TO
OUR PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY
ARE FOUNDATIONS TO PROVIDE OTHER
SUPPORTS THAT.
AND DOCUMENTS STUDENTS CAN
RECEIVE AND WHICH WE HAVE MANY
OF YES SO AS FAR AS THE THE THE
AID THE GOOD NEWS IS -- SO
MEMBER MEDINA AND MYSELF --
QUIRK SILVA GABRIEL AND BOERNER
HORVATH READ AT EVENT AND NINE
O'CLOCK AND WE UNVEILED.
A MAJOR -- FINANCIAL AID
PROPOSAL FROM THE ASSEMBLY RE
PUSHING.
FOR WE WILL WORK IN LAST COUPLE
YEARS TO DRAMATICALLY EXPAND
FINANCIALLY TO COVER.
NON TUITION COSTS FOR ACTUALLY
COLLEGES YES YOU YOU SEE AND
OTHER CALLS AS WELL SO.
THAT'S CERTAINLY IN OUR AGENDA
TO TO TO PUSH THIS YEAR -- I
YEAH AS THE THE THE OTHER
QUESTION THAT -- THAT MR DOLLARS
TALKING ABOUT SUCCESS IT'S IT'S
NOT JUST MORE IN ROMAN WHICH IS
A GOOD THING WE NEED MORE COURSE.
YOU KNOW HELPS YOU FINANCE SO
YOU'RE DISTRICTS BUT WE NEED
MORE.
OF PEOPLE WITH THAT COLLEGE
EDUCATION DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES BUT YOU'RE SHOWING
SUCCESS OF THE STUDENTS GOING
FULL TIME.
YEAH SELECT THAT RATS BRINKLEY A
BIGGER VICTORY BOTH THE HUGE
VICTORY -- BECAUSE INCENTIVIZING
FOR BECAUSE WE KNOW STUDENTS
REMAIN FULL TIME TO COMMITTED
THE TASK OF THE DO BETTER THE
OUR ELDER ARE ABLE TO STAY ON
CAMPUS A LOT MORE TO RECEIVE THE
OTHER KINDS OF SUPPORTS AROUND
THEM.
THE BILL LEARNING COHORTS FULL
TIME MATTERS IS PROBABLY THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT SUCCESS
FACTOR FOR STUDENTS AND THAT
GOES ACROSSINCOMING GOES ACROSS
AGE FULL TIME ENROLLMENT.
OKAY SO THAT THE REASON WE WE WE
INVITED YOU YOU HERE TODAY
BECAUSE LIKE.
EVERY OTHER GOVERNMENT PROGRAM I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
HAVE OVERSIGHT NOT TO JUST.
ASK YOU LAWS AND MOVE ON BY TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE DOING IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND AND WE WE'VE
HEARD STORIES I'VE HEARD FROM MY
LOCALS HERE LOS RIOS AT THIS.
IS THAT IS SIX TO SUCCESSFUL AND
SO WE OF COURSE ARE LOOKING TO
EXPAND IT TO YEAR -- TWO WE WERE
LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY ALL --
FULL TIME NOT JUST FIRST TIME
FULL TIME -- BRISTLE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT -- PENCILING OUT OUT
AND WE HAD SOME CONFLICTING
NUMBERS BACK AND FORTH SO I AS I
GUESS THE QUESTION YOU AND ASK
YOU HERE TODAY IS ABSENT FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
YOU'RE ALL INDEPENDENT AND YOU
DISTRICTS ANYWAY -- WHO ARE
THERE ANY TWEAKS THAT WE SHOULD
LOOK AT WITH WITH WITH THIS
PROGRAM BESIDES OBVIOUS YOU
SUPPORT?
YOUR TO ANYTHING THAT WE OUGHT
TO BE LOOKING AT AND DOING
DIFFERENTLY ANY ANY -- MORE
FLEXIBILITY LESS FLEXIBILITY
THIS IS YOUR CHANCE JUST TO
SHARE WITH US ABOUT THIS PROGRAM.
SO I WOULD SAY THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY I MENTIONED EARLIER
IS BOTH A BLESSING AND A CURSE
FOR US AND I THINK THE THE
MATCHING OF OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND HOW WE'RE DOING IT IS THE
KID IS THE KEY CHALLENGE SO WE
ARE DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS
STILL.
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
THOSE A. B. NINETEEN DOLLARS GET
EXPANDED -- WE WOULDN'T BE THERE
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR THE FACT
THAT WE ARE PRE EXISTING TWO
YEAR PRIVATELY FUNDED PROMISE
EFFORT.
AND SO I THINK THE THE
FLEXIBILITY IS GOOD ALTHOUGH THE
IDEAL FOR US WOULD BE THAT THAT
THE THE LEGISLATURE WOULD PROVE
THE FUNDS TO ACTUALLY.
BUY OUT THOSE FEES ACROSS THE
BOARD AND SIMPLIFY THAT SO THAT
AS AS WE WE MENTIONED EARLIER
YOU WITH THE CREATIVITY THAT THE
THAT THE PRIVATE PHILANTHROPIC
DOLLARS CAN CAN ADD TO THAT --
WOULD BE THE GOAL SO I WOULD SAY
IF IF WE COULD DO ANYTHING IT
WOULD BE TO MAKE THAT A SIMPLE.
FORMULA -- AND THEN TO USE THE
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS TO BE THE
OUT ON THIS -- AT THIS POINT
THOSE ARE NOT REPLACEABLE AND
THAT YOU KNOW THAT WAS CLARIFIED
EARLY ON A. B. NINETEEN THE
CHANCES OFFICE THAT IF YOU
ALREADY HAVE A A PROGRAM --
THESE DOLLARS MAYBE NINETY
CANNOT BE USED TO BUY THAT OUT
AND THEN AND THEN YOU MOVE ON
ULTIMATELY IF THIS IS SOLIDIFIED
AS AN ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE I
WOULD ARGUE THAT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEN WE
CAN GET.
THOSE OTHER DOLLARS APPLIED TO
THINGS LIKE HOUSING AND SECURITY
FOOD AND SECURITY OTHER KINDS OF
BRIDGE BUILDING AT SOME
CLARIFICATION FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS FAR AS IT
WHAT THE ISSUE HE'S RAISING IS
THAT.
CURRENTLY PERMISSIBLE HELP HELP
US UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ISSUE IS
HERE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE -- WE'VE GIVEN
DISTRICTS BROUGHT FLEXIBILITY
SIDE I DON'T WANT TO CONTRADICT
ANYTHING MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SHARED WITH FOLKS BUT I I WOULD
SAY IN GENERAL ARE APPROACH HAS
BEEN DISTRICTS HAVE -- KIT --
HAVE DISCRETION TO USE AB
NINETEEN FUNDS -- AND FURTHER
DISCRETION COMPARED TO EXISTING
LAW TO USE IT -- FOR FEE WAIVERS.
WELL I WOULD ONLY ADD FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
BECAUSE THERE IS IMPACTION AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES AND FRANK THAT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WHERE MANY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
ARE BEING TURNED AWAY BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT ENOUGH ELIGIBLE
SEATS AVAILABLE TO THEM HAS SOME
KIND OF FORMAL WAY.
THAT THEY CAN COME BACK TO US --
AS FIRST YEAR FULL TIME STUDENTS
WITH GUARANTEED ADMISSIONS IN A
ROMAN THEY GUARANTEE BACK THIRD
MISSION A TWO YEARS LATER
SOMETHING THAT WOULD MAKE THE
PROCESS A LOT MORE SEAMLESS.
SO THAT WE HAVE A HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM WORKING
TOGETHER. TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS
AND INTERESTS OF A HIGHER
EDUCATED COMMUNITY OF THAT IS
CALIFORNIA SOMETHING ALONG.
THOSE LINES -- TO TO ECHO ARE
VICE CHANCELLOR WE HAVE USED THE
FLEXIBILITY QUITE WELL.
NOT TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS SO THAT FOR US IS GOING
VERY WELL AND IS AND AND SINCE
OUR PARTICULAR NEEDS BUT I'D
LIKE.
TO PUT THIS I WHAT I BELIEVE IS
A MODEL LEGISLATION MODEL
PROGRAM IN THE CONTEXT OF ALL.
CALIFORNIA THREE TIERED HIGHER
EDUCATION SO THEY CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
YEAH.
HAS THE WORK FOR IS IT FIRST
TIME LET'S LET'S SAY YOU GO.
TO UC SANTA BARBARA FOR A
SEMESTER OR A YEAR.
LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT I NEED.
TO GO TO SANTA BARBARA CITY.
AND SO DOES IS THAT PERSON AT
FIRST TIME IF IT IS IS IS THE
FIRST TIME COMMITTEE CALL YOUR
FIRST TIME COLLEGE STUDENT.
IT'S PERCENT COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
AM YES THEY WOULD THEY WOULD
THEY WOULD QUALIFY FOR THAT WHAT
WELL IT JONES.
YEAH.
YET WHETHER I'M COLLEGE YOUR
FIRST TEN MINUTE CALL
[inaudible]
SPECIAL.
I WOULD SAY THE WAY WE'VE BEEN
ALLOCATING THE FUNDS IS ON THE
BASIS OF FIRST TIME AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE SO
IT DISTRICT WOULD GET FUNDS
BASED ON THE FIRST OF THE NUMBER
OF FIRST TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS -- AT THE COLLEGE I
WILL SAY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE STATUTE WE WEEKS EXPECT
THAT DISTRICTS ARE -- ARE
AWARDING THE FUNDS.
THE WAIVERS TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
NON CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISED
GRANT ELIGIBLE ONLY TO FIRST
TIME -- FULL TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT SAID I
THINK THAT'S A YEAH I THINK WE
HAVE -- NEED TO DO WORK THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS ART A FEW DO NOT
MEET THAT REQUIREMENT OR NOT
OTHERWISE GETTING FEE WAIVERS I
THINK THE ISSUE IS THAT OF THE
TWO MILLION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND IN A COUPLE OF
THOUSAND YOU SEE AN FIVE
THOUSAND CSU.
IT'S NOT ALL LINEAR PERFECT
EVERYONE HAS THE SAME TRACK
RIGHT IN ALL OF US HAD HAD
DIFFERENT A PATH TO TO GET WERE
RAT TODAY.
AND SO AS WE PUT THESE PROGRAMS --
FOURTH WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT YOU
KNOW HOW WE DON'T HAVE STUDENTS.
TRAPPED AND WE HAVE HOW WE HAVE --
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS I THINK I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
RIGHT HERE TODAY BUT AS WE LOOK
AT EXPAND.
THIS THIS PROMISE PROGRAM IS IS
WHAT.
CAN WE DO TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
TODAY.
IF I COULD ADD ONE ONE
SUGGESTION FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT IMPROVE THIS IS.
I THINK RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN DIFFERENT
MESSAGES GOING OUT ABOUT
PROMISES ME AND I THINK ONE
THING THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM
WHAT ORGANS DONE IN TENNESSEE IS
DONE.
IS MORE A UNIVERSAL MESSAGE IT'S
COMING I KNOW I KNOW THERE'S A
PROPOSED IF FOR SOME SUPPORT FOR
THIS UNIVERSAL MESSAGES COMING
FROM THE STATE LEVEL ABOUT THIS
ACCESS TO TUITION WILL STILL
WANT TO HAVE OUR LOCAL MESSAGING.
BUT SOMETHING THAT GETS THE WORD
OUT TO YOU STUDENTS PARENTS
FAMILIES -- TAXPAYERS PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT THIS
IS AVAILABLE TO OUR STUDENTS NOW
IN WHATEVER THE CONSISTENT
ELEMENT OF IT IS IF IT'S FEE
WAIVER FOR THAT'S CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT CAN NOW LIMIT IN THAT YOU
KNOW INDIVIDUAL BENEFITS MAY
VARY BY CAMPUS I THINK WE COULD
BE MORE EFFICIENT WITH OUR
DOLLARS AND MORE EFFICIENT WITH
OUR MESSAGING IF WE HAD MORE
CENTRALIZED EFFORT.
INCLUDE F. EXCUSE ME WHY IT
MATTERS.
WHY IT MATTERS CALIFORNIA HAS
THE ABILITY TO RADICALLY THE
TREMENDOUS WEALTH AND
OPPORTUNITY GAP THAT EXISTS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGH A
PROGRAM SUCH AS THIS?
THROUGH OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT THAT'S A REALLY
APPOINTMENTS NOT JUST TO GET IT
BUT WHY IT MATTERS TO BE
EDUCATED TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PARTICIPATE IN.
OF THE GIG ECONOMY THE
INNOVATION ECONOMY THOSE OTHER
TREMENDOUS ASSETS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A WITHOUT THESE
KINDS OF OPPORTUNITIES WE ARE
BUILDING A PERPETUATING -- A
SINGLE A WEALTH DISPARITY THAT
THAT WE CAN NO LONGER SUSTAIN SO.
YOU KNOW MY MESSED IT UP I'D I'D
LIKE TO INCLUDE -- WILL.
IN YOUR **** THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE MESSAGING WHY IT MATTERS
FOR CALIFORNIA AND WHY IT
MATTERS IN THE EQUITY EQUATION.
OKAY YES MISTER MCCARTY AYE I
KNOW YOU KNOW THIS SO I HESITATE
TO JUMP IN BUT I WOULD JUST SAY
YOU KNOW -- I THINK AS WE THINK
ABOUT EXPANDING THIS -- YOU KNOW
TODAY WE COLLECT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION --
AND FEES SO -- YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ESSENTIALLY --
EIGHTEEN AN INCREASE DECREASE IN
THAT AMOUNT BY ABOUT FORTY
MILLION I THINK LARGER
EXPANSIONS.
YOU KNOW WE'VE COST ABOUT AN
ESTIMATE OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MORE TO WAIVE
TUITION FOR NON FIRST TIME
STUDENTS WHO ARE FULL TIME.
I THINK THE YOU KNOW.
THE RULES OF THE GAME FOR THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS HAS BEEN WE WE
FUND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT THE
LEVEL REQUIRED BY PROP NINETY
EIGHT WE WOULD ARGUE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE THE RULES OF THE
GAME BUT TO THE EXTENT TO THOSE
REMAIN THE RULES THAT I THINK WE
IT I THINK.
THERE ARE HARD QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHERE THOSE STOP THOSE DOLLARS
DON'T GET BACK FILLED IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUDGET SO
WHAT WE DO TO SUPPORT THE COST
THAT I THINK ARE VERY REAL.
FOR FULL TIME FACULTY FOR OTHER
COSTS THAT WE ALSO KNOW IMPROVE
STUDENT SUCCESS OF OTHER
CULTURES.
AND I I WOULD SEPARATE THIS SORT
OF EXPERIMENTAL PHASE FROM THE
OTHER SO MIGHT MY COMMENT
EARLIER ABOUT THE BLESSING AND
CURSE OF THAT FLEXIBILITY IS
THAT RIGHT NOW THAT'S BEEN A
BLESSING TO BE ABLE. TO TO
FIGURE IT OUT -- THE CURBSIDE IS
THAT COMMUNICATION SIDE AND WHEN
ONCE WE'RE CLEAR ON THIS AND
THERE IS A LONG TERM FUNDING AT
WHATEVER LEVEL OF WEEK WE END UP
THAT I WOULD SAY SIMPLICITY IS
IS KEY -- I WE WE'VE FOUND THE
OF FORM FOLLOWS FUNCTION
STRUCTURE AND AN INCENTIVE
STRUCTURES CRITICAL SO WHATEVER
WE LAND ON WE NEED TO MAKE THAT
A SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE RATHER THAN
A NEW PROGRAM OR NEW APPLICATION.
SIMPLY USE THE STRONGEST PARTS
OF THE SYSTEM AS THEY ARE
BOLSTER THOSE AND THEN AND LET
THOSE YOU KNOW EXPERIMENTS
AROUND THE THE MARGINS OR WITH
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS --
CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD BUT
THAT THAT TO ME IS WHERE WE NEED
TO GOES AT THAT SIMPLE CLEAR
THIS IS WHAT WE DO THIS IS WHY
WE DO IT.
AND AND GIVE IT AND AND LET THE
FLEXIBILITY THEN COME AND AT AT
THE WITH WITH OTHER SORT OF
EXPERIMENTS ON THE MARGINS.
AND THEN DO YOU HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO USE SOME OF YOUR
YOUR CAMPUS MONEY. TO FOCUS ON
THE FOR FOR THAT FOR THE NON
FIRST TIME STUDENTS WE DO. TWO
OTHER FUNDS SOURCES CORRECT YEAH
BECAUSE IT WAS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO SUPPORT ALL
STUDENTS WHO ARE THERE SO THAT
IS CORRECT.
YEAH AND THERE'S FLEXIBILITY IN
THE STUDENT EQUITY IN ACCESS
FUNDS YEAH BUT TO DO THAT WHAT
ABOUT JUST GET TO THE OFFICE
WITH THE STATE MONEY.
IT IS IT WOULD HAVE THE FACT BUT
I'M I KNOW THAT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
GO AROUND OBVIOUSLY.
BUT WOULD THEY HAVE A CASE BY
CASE SITUATION OR HOW WOULD THAT
WORK WE HAVE LONG STATE.
STATURE REQUIRES COLLEGES TO
COLLECT THE ENROLLMENT FEE -- I
THINK THERE'S BEEN LONGSTANDING
INTERPRETATION THAT SUGGESTS
THAT -- USING STATE GENERAL
FUNDS WERE UP TO PAY ENROLLMENT
FEES WHO ARE NOT OTHERWISE --
FOR HIM BUT ROAMING FEES ARE NOT
OTHERWISE WAVE WOULD BE -- IS
NOT ALLOWED UNDER THOSE LAWS
WITHIN CLARIFICATION ABOUT
WHETHER COLLEGES CAN USE GENERAL --
FUNDS TO PAY ENROLLMENT FEES
WOULD BE -- WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND THAT THE ONLY THING I WOULD
ADD TO THAT SORT OF THE AS THE
AS THE PHILANTHROPY GUY HERE
TODAY WHO WHO'S WHO'S WORKING
PRIMARILY ON THAT PRIVATE
SUPPORT SIDE YOU KNOW IT
PHILANTHROPY IN THE COMMITTEE
CALLED SYSTEM IS VERY NEW --
RELATIVE TO THE FOR YOUR SYSTEM
AND AND IT SHOWS UP IN THE
NUMBERS ACROSS THE BOARD TO THE
DATA POINT I MOST OFTEN REPEAT
AS OF LATE IS THAT IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT AMERICANS GIVE TO
CHARITY -- WE CROSS FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS ACCORDING TO
GIVE US A TO A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO OF THAT THE SECOND LARGEST
PIECE GOES TO EDUCATION.
THAT'S JUST 14%.
BUT ONLY POINT 2% ACTUALLY COMES
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND YET WE
ARE HALF OF THE NATION'S COLLEGE
SERVING YOU KNOW SERVING HAVE
THIS NATION'S COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO I THINK IF IF WE WANT TO
INVEST IN THIS THE FLIGHT WE
SHOULD NEVER TAKE THE PLACE OF
OUR PUBLIC COMMITMENT -- BUT WE
CERTAINLY CAN BUILD AND LEVERAGE
THE PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERSHIPS
AROUND THIS SO IF WE GET CLEAR
IN MESSAGE WHAT THAT WE ARE
DOING AS A FROM THE PUBLIC SIDE
THAT THAT IS INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
TO THE BROADER COMMUNITY THAT
WANTS TO SUPPORT HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES REALLY
SHOULD MOVE TO THE CENTER OF
THAT AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE
TRY TO DO.
MISS RECORD IF I COULD WEIGH IN
ON HIS.
CREDIBLE POINT THERE.
IT ALSO DEALS WITH --
FINANCIALLY DISCUSSION THAT
YOU'RE LEADING.
THAT IS AND THE HERE'S THE POOL
OF HEALTH FUNDS AVAILABLE TO ALL
AMERICANS. FIFTY OR SO PERCENT
OF ALL HIGHER EDUCATION.
STUDENTS ARE OUT THE COMMITTEE
CALL JUST YET OF THE PILL FUNDS.
10% IS DISTRIBUTED TO THE KID TO
THE NATION'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
THE LARGEST SEGMENT SO WE'RE NOT
GETTING OUR FAIR SHARE THE BILL
FUNDS.
OF THOSE WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE
ELIGIBLE SO THAT IS OUR POLICY
DISCUSSIONS THAT ALL LEVERAGE
TOGETHER BRAIDED TOGETHER COULD
REALLY.
MAKE -- TOWARDS ADDRESSING IN
ADDRESSING THOSE GAPS IN THE
TOTAL COST OF TUITION.
THE COURT COLD ACOSTA CITY HAVE
A TENDENCY TO MAKE COLLEGE.
YEAH SO I I I I LOVE TO SING
THESE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA DOING IT ON THEIR OWN
TO HEAR AND WES ACT THEY PASSED
A BUT SALES TAX MEASURE IN THERE
BEING SOME TO THEIR PROMISE
PROGRAM -- IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
LA YOU'RE DOING IN SANTA BARBARA.
AND SO OF COURSE YOU CAN USE
THAT MONEY TO TO MAKE YOUR
PROGRAMS MORE ROBUST AND AND
COVER THAT BOOKS IN.
TUITION AND I MEAN I'M SORRY BUT
NOT TUITION TO BOOKS.
TRANSPORTATION AND SO FORTH.
WHAT DO WE THINK AS FAR AS THE
HUNDRED OR SO?
COMMITTEE CALL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HOW MANY OF THEM.
ARE USING OTHER MONEY TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR PROMISE
[inaudible]
FOR HI.
SO WE HAVE NOT DONE A SYSTEMATIC
ANALYSIS THERE WAS A RESEARCH
DONE LAST YEAR THAT SAID THERE
WERE FORTY TWO COMMUNITIES THAT
HAD -- PROMISE PROGRAMS THAT
LEVERAGE -- BOTH STATE FUNDS BUT
OTHER PRIVATE FUNDS.
IF AB HALF OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THIS IS
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE WITH BROAD
SUPPORT UP HERE IN.
WHERE CERTAINLY GOING TO SUPPORT?
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WHICH
YOU KNOW WAS PART OF OUR
RECOGNITION TO OUR BILL AS WELL.
AND YOU KNOW LOOKING TO STRENGTH
AS WELL SO KEEP.
US INFORMED HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS
PROGRAM.
WORK EVEN BETTER FOR
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU FOR
COMING I THINK YOU.
ALL THIS ISSUE OFTEN -- WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY [inaudible]
AGENDA ITEM.
AND WE ARE GOING -- TO TO TAKE A
VOTE ON THIS ISSUE.
TRYING TO GET SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS BACK HERE WE CAN TAKE A
AN AXE ITEM ON THIS.
OKAY PLEASE WE GET READY CUTS --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU.
SURE MCCARTY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS THE HEALTH PLAN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL PROVIDES
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE MILLION
AND YOUR BONTA STORY FOR FIFTEEN
CONTINUING AND FIFTEEN NEW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
PROJECTS STATE WIDE.
SHOULD THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
BE APPROVED SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR MILLION OF THE TWO BILLION
AND PROP FIFTY ONE FUNDS
PROVIDED FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BE OBLIGATED.
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CRITERIA FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT FUNDING
STATEWIDE THE PROJECT
RECOMMENDED FOR FUNDING ADDRESS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FIRE
LIFE SAFETY ISSUES.
OF FIRE LIFE SAFETY ISSUES --
AREN'T NECESSARILY THE SOLE
REASON FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROJECT TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
FUNDING IT SHOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER.
DETERMINING WHICH PROJECTS TO BE
FUNDED THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERS WHETHER A REQUESTING
DISTRICT CAN PROVIDE SOME LEVEL
OF FUNDING MATCH WITH OUR
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
PREVENT THE DISTRICT FROM
CONTRIBUTING.
EXAMPLE OF THE LATTER WOULD
INCLUDE REDWOOD COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A SMALL DISTRICT WITH
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
RESULTING FROM RECENT SEISMIC
ANALYSES.
OTHER EXAMPLES WOULD BE A RECENT
UNSUCCESSFUL ATTEMPT AT PASSING
A LOCAL BOND OR DEMONSTRATING
THAT DISTRICT HAS REACHED ITS
THE BOND CAPACITY -- CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN RAISED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH
CREATES A DISINCENTIVE FOR
DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN THE
FACILITY -- HOWEVER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NO TO NEED FOR
SIXTEEN POINT SIX BILLION IN
STATE FUNDS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS WELL IN THAT ACCESS OF THE
REMAINING ONE POINT THREE
BILLION AND PROP -- FIFTY ONE
BOND FUNDS.
THEREFORE WE FIND UNLIKELY THAT
COLLEGES OF PURPLE SO THEY ALLOW
THEIR BUILDINGS TO FALL INTO
DISREPAIR.
RISKING THE SAFETY OF ITS
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU EL áREA.
I RIVER BRAWL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
OF PREDICT TWO RECOMMENDATIONS
WITH THIS ISSUE THE FIRST THING
WE RECOMMEND IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER APPROVING
MORE -- PROVING MORE PROP FIFTY
ONE BOND FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAN WHAT WAS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- WE NOTED
THAT -- THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES
THE NEWS THE MINISTRATION DOES
INCLUDE.
MANY MORE PROJECTS IN IN THEIR
BUDGET THEM WERE WERE INCLUDED
IN PREVIOUS BUDGET UNDER THE
BRAND ADMINISTRATION.
THE STATE IS STILL ON PRETTY
SLOW PACE FOR EXHAUSTING ALL THE
PROFITS. FIFTY ONE BOND FUNDS
THE AT THIS POINT IT'S AT THE
BOTTOM NINE YEAR PIECE -- TO TO
TO EXHAUST ALL THOSE FUNDS.
I'M USED TO THAT WAS THE THE
FIRST THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE THE SECOND OR THIRD
RECOMMENDATIONS IS GREAT -- TOO
ADDRESSES CAN ACT ISSUE OF HOW
LIFE SAFETY PROJECT AND HOW
LIGHT THE FUSE USED IN
EVALUATING -- WHETHER PROJECTS
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET.
I'M THE THE CHANCES OF IT HAS A
LONG STANDING PROCESS -- FOR
THAT WITH A SORE SEPARATE --
WITH A REVIEW LIVE FIFTY
PROJECTS AND THEN ALL THE OTHER
PROJECTS ARE ARE EVALUATED BASED
ON OTHER NEEDS SUCH AS WHETHER
THERE'S A NEED FOR MODERNIZATION
OR FOR ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTION
CAPACITY.
I'M THE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN ALSO LOOKING AT THROUGH A
DIFFERENT LIFE SAFETY LENDS IT
LOOKING UP ALL PROJECTS THAT WAY
WE JUST CREATED A LOT OF
CONFUSION FOR DISTRICTS -- IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THE PROJECT ARE BEING
APPROVED IN WHICH PROJECTS ARE
GOOD CANDIDATES FOR BEING
SUBMITTED.
AND WE THINK ALSO -- BY LOOKING
AT EVERYTHING TO REALIZE THE
VILLAINS ACTUALLY -- MEANS THAT
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH WOULD BE PRIORITIZING
PROJECTS.
IN DISTRICTS THAT POTENTIALLY
WOULD HAVE DONE A POOR JOB OF
MAINTAINING THE BUILDINGS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ARE REQUIRE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO COME
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP ONE AGREED
UPON -- CRITERIA FOR HOW TO
REVIEW LIFE SAFETY PROJECTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHRIS TRUST
WHENEVER THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
I'M STARTING ON PAGE TWELVE OF
THE HAND OUT THAT -- DISTRIBUTED
EARLIER I JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE
SOME BACKGROUND ON
INFRASTRUCTURE GENERALLY TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT FOR THIS
CONVERSATION.
YOU ALL EQUIRE US TO PRODUCE A
FIVE YEAR CAPITAL PLAN THAT
IDENTIFIES NEEDS AND PRIORITIES
OUR CURRENT -- PLAN FIVE YEAR
PLAN PROJECTS NEEDS -- THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF THAT ABOUT
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IS FOR
NEW FACILITIES ABOUT TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS FOR
MODERNIZATION OF EXISTING
FACILITIES.
CLEARLY THAT -- FAR EXCEEDS THE
AMOUNT OF STATE FUNDS -- THAT
HAVE BEEN A PER -- AUTHORIZED --
IN RECENT YEARS I COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS PRIMARILY RELY
ON LOCAL FUNDS INCLUDING LOCAL
BONDS TO MEET THEIR CAPITAL
NEEDS THE STATE ALSO PROVIDES
CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDS DISTRICTS
CAN GENERATE OTHER SOURCES LIKE
GIFTS OR DONATIONS.
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE ENACTED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN OPERATES TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDS AND SO --
WHAT WE HAVE ASKED FOR A FOLLOWS
THE PROCESS OF PRIVATIZATION
THAT TAKES PLACE WITHIN THE
SYSTEM SO I JUST WANTED TO
DESCRIBE A BIT OF HOW THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE -- PUTS
TOGETHER THE REQUEST THAT IT
SUBMITS TO BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND TO YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
TWELVE YOU'LL SEE.
OF THE RIGHT HAND SIDE A CHART
THAT SHOWS SIX CATEGORIES OF
PROJECTS.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE SAY IS USING
A VERY STRICT DEFINITION OF FIRE
LIFE SAFETY ANY.
FIRE LIFE SAFETY PROJECTS WHAT
WE CALL A CATEGORY A YOU GET
INCLUDED IN OUR REQUEST.
THAT THE REMAINING DOLLARS THAT
WE THINK ARE AVAILABLE FOR THAT
YEAR I GET DISTRIBUTED ACROSS A
NUMBER FIVE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES.
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON GROWTH AND
INSTRUCTIONAL SPACE.
WE ALSO INCLUDE A MODERNIZATION
OF INSTRUCTIONAL SPACE -- A
CATEGORY THAT INCLUDES
FACILITIES THAT WOULD HELP TO
BUILD OUT A COMPREHENSIVE CAMPUS.
ABOUT BOTH FOR MODERNIZATION --
CATEGORIES OF INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPPORT AND INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPPORT GROWTH.
AND SO TURNING TO PAGE THIRTEEN
AS THE PUBLIC SIDE OF ANALYSTS
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE OF NOTED
ARE SPENDING PLAN THAT WE HAD
PROPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
INCLUDED PROJECTS TOTALING FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE NINETEEN ARE
CONTINUING PROJECTS FOR TOTAL
COST OF FIVE HUNDRED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS LARGELY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION AND EQUIPMENT
PHASES OF THOSE PROJECTS.
A BIT OF ALSO INCLUDED THIRTY
NINE NEW PROJECTS TOTAL COSTS OF
FORTY EIGHT MILLION LARGELY FOR
PLANNING AND WORKING DRAWINGS.
WE APPRECIATE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THAT WOULD FUND
THAT REQUESTED I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SO THIS IS AN ITEM THAT --
OBVIOUSLY -- THE VOTERS -- SPOKE
TWO YEARS AGO LOUDLY WHEN THEY
PASS THE THE BOND FOR K. THROUGH
FOURTEEN EDUCATION -- FACILITIES
AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT THE LAST
YOU BUDGETS HAVEN'T I RECOGNIZE
THAT COMMITMENT SO -- WE WE WANT
TO DO TODAY IS TO APPROVE THE
THE PRO THE THE PROPOSALS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S.
INITIAL BUDGET AS WELL AS ADD TO
THE OTHER -- PROJECTS IN THE IN
THE AGENDA ITEM -- WRITTEN UP BY
BY OUR STAFF ON PAGE AT OUR
COLLEGES NEED ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND AGAIN -- IT HERE TO THE WILL
OF THE VOTERS CELL WITHOUT
LOOKING FOR MOTION.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AS WELL
AS THE ADDITIONAL PROJECTS
LISTED ON PAGE TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY FOUR SO I WITHOUT EMOTION
A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MCCARTY.
HI [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
MOTION PASSES OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALREADY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
AYE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ONLINE
[inaudible]
OKAY RIGHT [inaudible]
GREAT.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S HEATHER
HYLES I AM THE RELATIVELY NEWLY
INSTALLED CEO TO THE CALIFORNIA
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- I
WAS LOOKING FOR TO JUST GIVING
YOU A BRIEF UPDATE AND THEN
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IN
OUR PROCESS -- AND WITH ME IS
JULIAN ROBERTS WHO IS THE CFO
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOUNDATION [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING -- I'VE BEEN ON THE
JOB A LITTLE LESS THAN -- A
LITTLE UNDER THREE MONTHS NOW
AND SO FAR WHAT WE'VE PRIORITIZE
IS -- SELECTING A NAME FOR THE
COLLEGE -- AND ALSO -- WORKING
KIND OF BACKWARDS FROM SOME OF
THE DELIVERABLES THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN ON WITH THE COLLEGE.
NAMELY THE MOST IMPORTANT BEING --
ESTABLISHING OUR FIRST SET OF
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WILL
LAUNCH ON OCTOBER FIRST -- AND
THEY INCLUDE ONE IN MEDICAL
CODING.
A SECOND IN I. T. FUNDAMENTALS
AND A THIRD AND CYBERSECURITY.
AND SO WE ARE DOING ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO TO SET
UP.
OUR CLOUT OUR COLLEGE AND
DISTRICT TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
THOSE TRAINING PROGRAM STARTING
OCTOBER -- ONE WE WILL ACTUALLY
START ENROLLING STUDENTS --
AUGUST IN AUGUST -- THERE ARE SO
MANY THINGS THAT ARE WITH THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE'RE JUST IN THE
PROCESS OF SETTING UP THAT -- I
COULD SPEND THE REST OF THE DAY
TELLING YOU ABOUT THOSE BUT
PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'RE
STARTING TO RECRUIT A AN
EXECUTIVE TEAM. TO FOCUS ON WE
HAVE IN PLACE ARE CTO BUT WE
STILL NEED -- THINGS.
POSITIONS FILLED SUCH AS A CO --
A CFO ACHIEVE SUCCESS OFFICER.
A CHIEF LEARNING OFFICER
ETCETERA [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEY ARE READY.
I'M I'M I'M HERE I'M JUST BACK.
OKAY YEP YEP GOTCHA -- SO YOU
CAN YOU WANT TO CAN YOU OUTLINE
A BIT MORE ON THE ON ON THE TWO
PROGRAMS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
THE ROLLOUT YEAH THEY'RE
ACTUALLY THREE DIFFERENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
GONNA LAUNCH -- AND THEY ARE AS
I MENTIONED MEDICAL CODING ONE
IS -- SO IT IS SECOND IS THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF IT AND THIRD IS
CYBERSECURITY -- WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS THAT MEDICAL
CODING ACTUALLY WAS IDENTIFIED
BY THE MEMBERS OF S. CI YOU.
AS A A GREAT PAYING JOB AND A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY FOR ITS
MEMBERS TO GET ADDITIONAL SKILLS.
AND TO GET PLACED INTO THOSE
JOBS AND I THINK IT'S A VERY
INTERESTING OPPORTUNITY -- FOR
WORKING WITH WORKING ADULTS AND
AND IMPARTING IN IMPRESSING UPON
THEM THE FACT THAT -- THIS
TRAINING PROGRAM GETS THEM.
INTO THE SECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
AND PREPARED VERY WELL PREPARED
FOR WORKING IN THAT -- SECTOR IN
THE FUTURE BUT THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY JOBS THAT ARE BEING
MADE OBSOLETE THROUGH OBSOLETE
THROUGH DIFFERENT KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGY.
AND SO I THINK IT'S A REALLY
GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO ILLUSTRATE
TO PEOPLE THAT IT'S NOT THE
FINAL DESTINATION IN A JOB BUT
IT IS THE STARTING.
POINT -- FOR MANY DIFFERENT
TYPES OF JOBS THAT COULD BE IN
THAT SECTOR -- AND AND THE THIS
VOTE I'M SORRY I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU AND AND SO WE
THINK THAT.
IT'S INTERESTING -- TO TO REALLY
IMPRESS UPON PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
WORKING AN ECONOMY THAT IS --
CHANGING EVER MORE RAPIDLY AND
THE PEOPLE WILL NEED TO PROVIDE
AND ACQUIRE NEW SKILLS TO STAY
RELEVANT.
AND TO THRIVE AND SO THIS IS A
REALLY GOOD ILLUSTRATION -- I
THINK OF THAT PARTICULAR POINT.
UNLIKE CYBERSECURITY WHICH IS
THE SECOND TRACK THAT WE
SELECTED WHERE THERE IS -- AN
EXPLOSION OF NEW TYPES OF JOBS
IN NEW RESPONSIBILITIES EVER IT
YOU KNOW INCREASING -- IN THE
CYBER SECURITY AREA.
BUT YET -- YOU CAN BE AN
ADMINISTRATOR LEARN THE FIRST
KIND OF LEVEL OF CYBER SECURITY
PROTOCOL AND INCREASE YOUR
SALARY BY SAY TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO -- SO THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TRAINING MODELS -- OR
TWO DIFFERENT KINDS OF I THINK
EXPERIENCES THAT OUR FOLKS WE'LL
GET TO THOSE PROGRAMS -- YOU'LL
RECALL THAT WE ARE.
BUILDING SKILLS UPGRADING
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THE OVER EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDEREMPLOYED TODAY.
OUR CANCERS OFFICE CHRISTIAN
CAME UP TO THE SEVENTIES ARE
KIND.
TO FOR TYPE QUESTION.
OF COURSE YOU HAVE YOUR JOB AND
I RESPECT THAT AND I KNOW WE
HAVE -- YET MANY BECAUSE I
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND HAS THERE BEEN ANY FEEDBACK
OR PUSHED BACK AT ALL FROM THE
DUPLICATION.
POTENTIAL.
AND AND COMPETITION CHRISTIAN --
I THINK WE'VE HEARD YOU KNOW WE
HEARD MUCH OF THE FEEDBACK LAST
YEAR AS THIS COLLEGE -- YOU KNOW
THIS IS BEING CONSIDERED BY THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW I THINK --
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CONVERSATION
THAT DISTRICTS OFFER -- SIMILAR
PROGRAMS I WOULD SAY THE
DIFFERENCE.
BETWEEN WHAT WE SEE THE ONLINE
COLLEGE OFFERING IS THAT IT'S
PROGRAMS WILL BE COMPETENCY
BASED IN A WAY THAT -- THE
PROGRAMS IN SIMILAR FIELDS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY AT THE AT THE
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THEN -- AS FAR AS THE THE
THE STRUCTURE.
THAT -- THAT THE FEE STRUCTURE
IT IT HAS THAT BEEN SETTLED
YETTER W. THE SAME AS THEY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HE STRUCTURE I
WOULD DEFER TO UP PRESIDENT
HOUSE.
THANK YOU -- SO WE ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING ON A MODEL WHEREBY WE
EXPECT AND PLAYERS TO PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE TO PREPARE.
THE WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW AND
THEIR WORK FORCE OF FROM
CALIFORNIA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
POPULATION.
AND SO WE ARE PLANNING TO
ACTUALLY INVEST IN OUR LEARNERS
AND HAVE EMPLOYERS INVEST IN
THOSE LEARNERS RATHER THAN
PASSING ALONG THE FEES TO THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES -- WE THINK
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO INVEST
TONS IN THE FORM OF SWEAT EQUITY
AND DON'T NEED TO ACTUALLY PAY
MORE MONEY THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
FOR THESE.
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THAT THE
STATURE DOES CLICK.
THE SPECIFIED A CLEAR STANDARD
GENERALLY ABOUT THE FEES CHARGED
BY THE ONLINE COLLEGE -- CONSIST
OF THOSE CHARGED AT THE OTHER
COLLEGES I THINK OUR OFFICE HAS
A ROLE TO MAKE SURE THAT'S THE
CASE I DON'T THINK WE'RE THERE
YET.
SO PAID BY THE EMPLOYER WHAT IF
THERE IS NO EMPLOYER WITH AND IF
YOU NEED WELL AND TO GET THERE
THAT IS ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES
IN OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS --
COMPARED TO A TRADITIONAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE ARE
ACTUALLY TRAIN PEOPLE FOR JOBS
THAT EXIST -- AS DEFINED BY THE
EMPLOYERS AND WE WORK WITH THEM
IN THEIR CURRICULA TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT ARE -- TRAINEES HAVE
ACQUIRED THE COMPETENCIES FOR
THEIR JOBS WE ALSO ARE BUILDING
IN PAID WORK EXPERIENCE OR
APPRENTICESHIP INTO OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS -- SO THESE ARE REALLY
DRIVEN BY EXISTING JOBS WITH
EMPLOYERS AT THE FRONT END AND
THROUGHOUT OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS.
SO THE THEIR PROGRAMS WILL ONLY
BE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
SANCTIONED AND ESSENTIALLY
PARTNER WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
WORK YEAH AN EMPLOYER CORRECT.
YEAH.
OKAY AND THEN AS FAR AS THE THAT
AND THEN -- I'M SORRY JUST -- TO
ADD TO THAT THEN ALSO ARE BUDGET
WILL BE GOING OUR INTERNAL FUNDS
WILL BE GOING TOWARDS PROVIDING
MORE OF WHAT SOME MIGHT CALL
WRAPAROUND SERVICES BUT WE
BELIEVE ARE CRITICAL. TO OUR
LEARNERS BEING SUCCESSFUL ON THE
JOB SO THAT IS HAVING COACHING
AND A LOT OF LIFE SKILLS
TRAINING ON BOTH THE FRONT END
OF THE TRAINING AS WELL AS ONCE
THEY'RE PLACED INTO THE JOBS.
AND THEN HISTORICALLY ONLINE
HIGHER EDUCATION HAS BEEN A
MIXED BAG -- YOU KNOW FRANKLY
FOR STUDENTS.
HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE MORE
EDUCATION BACKGROUND IT'S BEEN
MORE SUCCESSFUL FOR THEM.
IN STUDENTS WHO ARE.
HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WORK AND EDUCATION WHERE THE ALL
THE HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
IT IS NOT ALWAYS EASY NAVIGATING
AS WE TALK IN OUR PRIOR JEFF
PANEL FIRST FIRST GENERATION
SEEDS ARE SO FORTH.
SO -- OF COURSE OUR STUDENTS
SERVICES WHICH ARE EXTREMELY YOU
KNOW HOW VALUABLE AND AND AND
REALLY NEEDED TO HELP SHE HAS
CROSSED THE FINISH LINE.
SELL IT ONLINE.
YOU KNOW I'LL BE ON YOUR PHONE
OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
HOW'S THAT GOING TO WORK OUT HOW
WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE STUDENTS
AREN'T SLIPPING THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
OF WELL AGAIN WE ARE RECRUITING
FOLKS WHO ARE ALREADY WORKING
BUT THEY ARE UNDER EMPLOYED.
SO THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL SKILLS SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE BETTER JOBS AND
HOPEFULLY ONE JOB WITH BENEFITS
RATHER THAN THREE JOBS WITHOUT
BENEFITS.
SO WE HAVE ARE WORKING WITH A
HIGHLY MOTIVATED POPULATION WHO --
WILL NEED BOTH A COMBINATION OF
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITY -- WITH FLEXIBLE
TIME TO BE ABLE -- TO ACQUIRED
NEW HARD SKILLS THROUGH ONLINE --
I RAN A PORTFOLIO -- WITH THE
BILL MELINDA GATES FOUNDATION
WHERE I STUDIED SPECIFICALLY HOW
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION REFORM
DIGITAL LEARNING ADVISING AND
FINANCIAL SECURITY SUPPORTS
EMERGENCY AID FINANCIAL AID
WOULD HELP FIRST GENERATION AND
UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITIES
COMPLETE COLLEGE I THINK I'M A
BIT OF A THE QUESTION IS MORE
ABOUT.
SUPPORT SERVICES SO THERE ARE
HIGHLY MOTIVATED INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE JOBS TO GO.
TO LA CITY COLLEGE YES THEY
STILL.
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES NEED THE
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT SERVICE
NOT THE EDUCATION PIECE AND SO.
YOU KNOW THAT'S THERE AND SO
CLEARLY THERE IS THAT E. L. P.
OFF A SOON SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS
AND POINT THEY A MO JO WHAT HAVE
YOU WHEN YOU'RE AT A CAMPUS YES
HOW WITH THOSE STUDENTS.
BE ABLE TO DO THIS ON THIS
VIRTUAL SO THAT OUR TWO THINGS
WERE IN ITSELF ANY HELP. TWO
ANSWERS THE QUESTION ONE IS THAT
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR
PROGRAM IS NOT GOING TO BE FULLY
ONLINE.
THAT THERE WILL BE IN PERSON
CONTACTS BETWEEN -- THIS LEARNER
AND A MENTOR AS WELL AS A COACH
WHO'S HELPING THEM NAVIGATE THE
WORKPLACE LEARNING HOW TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
SUPERVISORS ALL THE THINGS THAT
ONE NEEDS TO DO TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL ON THE JOB.
AND THESE COACHES WILL BE WITH
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS -- FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF AN APPRAISAL PERIOD
THROUGH THE ACTUAL TRAINING.
BOTH ONLINE AS WELL AS WHILE
THEY'RE AT THE WORK SITE AS WELL
AS ONCE THEY'RE PLACED INTO THE
JOB WAS SUCCESS OFFICERS WORKING
WITH THEM. TO CONTINUE TO HELP
THEM -- GROW AND DEVELOP AND
THEIR JOBS -- AND SO -- AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE SOME OF THE
CEOS OF SOME OF THE OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES A
SPECIFICALLY I'M THINKING OF THE
KEVIN WHO RUNS -- COMPTON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- SAID YOU
KNOW WE ALSO NEED ONLINE
TUTORING SUPPORTS AND SO IF YOU
CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGICAL SUPPORT SHE GET
INTO DURING.
THAT WOULD REALLY HELP OUR
STUDENTS AS WELL SO WE KNOW THAT
WE NEED BOTH -- REAL TIME ACCESS
TO INFORMATION AND CONTENT FOR
FREE THREE DEVICES AS WELL AS A
LOT OF FOLKS IN OUR PROGRAM DO
NOT HAVE THE NETWORK STEVEN GET
INTERVIEWS TO THE RIGHT JOBS.
AND WE'RE HERE TO HELP THEM
BUILD THEIR FIRST PROFESSIONAL
NETWORKS.
OKAY SOME AMERO DONNA.
YES THANK YOU AND I'M.
I'M EVERY TIME I HEAR ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM I HEAR SOMETHING NEW I
DIDN'T KNOW THERE WAS GOING TO
BE AN OUT OF CLASSROOM EXTRA --
OFFLINE EXPERIENCE YEP -- SO
LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SO
SO YOU'VE CITED -- REITER
STARTING ON MEDICAL CODING
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT.
AND CYBERSECURITY AND FIRST LINE
SUPERVISION SO THOSE ARE
AVAILABLE AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WILL THE WILL OF THE QUICK
BUT THEY WILL BE AVAILABLE
ONLINE.
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE WHOLE
INTENT OF THIS PROGRAM.
THAT'D BE SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT
AVAILABLE.
AT AT AT YOUR STANDARD YOU A
COLLEGE ONLINE.
IT IS I THINK WE WOULD SAY THE
COMMITMENT -- WE AGREE THAT
THERE.
YEAH THIS WAS THE CONCERN THE
COMMITMENT WAS THAT PROGRAMS
DESIGNED IN THIS WAY WOULD NOT
BE OFFERED AT THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY OFFERED AT OTHER
COLLEGES.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS FIRST FULL MEMBER --
DOWNLOAD LEFT TAKE KNOWLEDGE THE
FACT THAT -- LIKE ANY OTHER
START UP THERE ARE A WHOLE LOT
OF GREAT INTENTIONS AND A BROAD
OUTLINE THAT WERE CREATED BEFORE
I WAS HIRED.
BUT NOW THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING YOU'LL GET A LOT
MORE DETAIL AND I'D BE DELIGHTED
TO COME AND SHARE AS OFTEN AS
YOU LIKE WHERE WE ARE.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HEAR NEW
INFORMATION EVERY SINGLE TIME IN
FRONT OF YOU SO I JUST WANT TO
POINT THAT OUT TO YOU.
ON THE OTHER THING IS THAT THERE
ARE MEDICAL CODING PROGRAMS AND
ALSO CYBERSECURITY PROGRAMS
TAUGHT AT OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT NOT IN THE WAY THAT
I'VE DESCRIBED THAT IS HAS
EMPLOYERS ON THE FRONT END WE'RE
WE'RE TRAINING THEM FOR SPECIFIC
JOBS THAT EXIST FROM THE
EMPLOYERS.
AND THAT INCLUDES -- APPLIED
LEARNING EXPERIENCES PLUS
COACHING ON THE BACK END OKAY
AND UNDERSTAND WHERE I'M COMING
BECAUSE I HAVE A DUTY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THE CONCEPTS AND
REALLY THE PROMISES THAT WERE
MADE AS THIS WAS.
DEVELOPED ARE CAN.
GRAHAM I'M GETTING AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF DELIVERABLES ACCORDING TO
THE STATUTE AND WE'RE ABIDING BY
ALL OF US I'M NOT JUST ABOUT
STATURE HAMAS ABOUT INTENT.
AND AND WE HAVE AN EXISTING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM I DON'T
WANT TO SEE THIS JUST GO ON YOU
SIR.
THEIR ROLE THAT'S WHAT RIGHT I
MEAN I'M IN I'M GOING TO REMAIN
I REMAIN I REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT I REMAIN VERY
CONCERNED.
THAT THIS MAY YOU SERVE THE ROLE.
OF OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHEN
THAT WAS NEVER THE INTENT
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE POINT OF
DISCUSSION IN THIS ROOM.
IN AND OUT OF THIS ROOM AS THIS
WAS A THIS WITH THIS WAS
CONTEMPLATED BUT I WILL JUST --
YOU KNOW I THINK.
MOST OF THE DAY TODAY WORK IS
NOW TRANCE.
TRANSFER TO THE INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES AS OTHER COLLEGES BUT I
THINK A ROLE FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE -- THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO
PLAY IS TO COMMUNICATE BE
COMMITMENTS THAT WERE MADE TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
OUGHT TO THE COLLEGES LEADERSHIP
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE DIRECTION --
IS CONSISTENT WITH THOSE I
COMMITMENTS OR THAT WE COME HERE
AGAIN AND AND TO THE EXTENT WE
DEVIATE FROM THOSE COMMITMENTS --
MAKE THAT CLEAR TO YOU ALL AND
AND SEE SHOULDN'T DEVIATE FROM
THIS GOVERNMENT'S.
MANY BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE OKAY THANK YOU --
THANK YOU MAKING THAT POINT.
SO SO NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
COACH IS THAT AND INSTRUCTORS
THAT WOULD SOMEONE CERTIFIED IS
AT SOME WITH SOME LEVEL OF
EDUCATION IS THAT SOMEONE IN
STATE IS THAT SOMEONE SITTING IN.
IN TEXAS ONLINE TO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE THAT.
THAT WAS THAT WAS ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WHICH ARE WE GONNA HAVE
PEOPLE TEACHING FROM FAR AWAY.
THAT MAY NOT EVEN HAVE
CERTIFICATIONS WERE RECRUITING
ALL OF OUR WORK FORCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE BORN IN LA -- ATTENDED UC
BERKELEY BUT I'VE BEEN HERE WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF BUSINESS SCHOOL
FOR OVER -- FOOTBALL FROM MY
FIFTY YEARS OF LIFE SO -- WHEAT
BUT WE ARE RECRUITING
EXCLUSIVELY CALIFORNIANS FOR OUR
JOBS.
AND SO THERE WAS AT THE HEAD
HUNTER CONTRACT WHAT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR IT
WAS -- IT ACTUALLY FINISHED.
THERE WAS A HEAD HUNTER CON WELL
I DON'T KNOW IT WASN'T A
CONTRACT ON OF A SOLE SOURCE
HOUSE ON WHATEVER SOLE SOURCE OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR.
DEAL I DON'T KNOW -- I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT WOULD EVEN BE LEGAL.
BUT THERE WAS A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SOLE SOURCE
CONTRACT OF SO IT WASN'T A
CONTRACT I DON'T KNOW JUST
HANDSHAKE I DON'T KNOW. TO TO AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR FIRST THAT JUST
FOR SEVEN POSITIONS TALK TO ME
ABOUT THAT WALK ME THROUGH WHERE
THEY WANT TO THIS [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY GOODNESS FOR THE SO IS
THAT ACCURATE OR SENT THAT IS
NOT ACCURATE EXACTLY -- SO FIRST
OF ALL WE I RETAINED A RECRUITER --
AS IS LEGAL TO ENGAGE WITH A FOR
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES CONTRACT
WITH A RECRUITER -- AS I
MENTIONED TO YOU -- ALTHOUGH
I'VE BEEN ON THE JOB ALMOST
THREE MONTHS NOW -- IN ORDER TO
GET OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS UP AND
RUNNING BY OCTOBER FIRST THEN
HIT ALL THE OTHER MILES THE
STONES MANDATED THIS YEAR -- I
NEED A FULL TEAM IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE WORK STATEWIDE --
AND I WANTED TO FIND A RECRUITER
WHO COULD WORK WITH ME AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE A LOT OF
RECRUITERS I'VE I'VE TALKED WITH --
TO HIRE -- SEVEN SIX SENIOR
LEVEL POSITIONS COULD SPEND AS
MUCH AS A YEAR DOING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A WHOLE YEAR.
SO I FELT LIKE I NEEDED TO RICKY
ENGAGE RECRUITERS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE -- IS FULLY LEGAL TO DO
SO AND OUR CONTRACT ENDED UP
BEING -- ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND AND IN
TOTAL -- SOME SO SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS THAN INITIALLY THE UP.
UPWARDS AMOUNT -- WAS INITIALLY
CAPTAIN APPROVED BY MY BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AT AT OVER
500-050-01000 DOLLARS AND YOU
MAY HAVE BEEN TOTALLY LEGAL I
DON'T KNOW THAT I DON'T YEAH.
BUT YOU KNOW FROM WHAT I READ I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS GOOD GOOD
PRACTICE ARE GOOD POLICY.
WE WILL BE GOING -- TO TO THE
FULL STATE -- FOR ALL VENDORS TO
RESPOND IN OUR R. F. P. FOR THE
ACTUAL TRAINING PROGRAMS --
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU THAT
I'VE JUST WE ARE OUT THAT WE
WILL BE TIME AND YEAH HEAD
HUNTER EXACTLY -- CRUDER TO TO
FIND AN EXECUTIVE TEAM STATEWIDE
EVEN CORRECT I WAS JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE ONE TIME HEAD HUNTER
DEAL.
THAT I READ ABOUT.
AND I STILL HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT DEAL WITH LET'S JUST LEAVE
IT AT THAT FOR NOW.
THANK YOU.
THE LETTER LIMóN ON THIS TOPIC
I AM.
WHAT I HEARD AND AND I REMEMBER
BEING IN THE HEARINGS LAST YEAR
AND THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT WAS
THAT THIS WOULD NOT [inaudible]
REPLICATE.
ANY COURSES OFFERED.
THE NEW ONES THAT I JUST HEARD
YOU SAY IS THAT.
IT'S A DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE HOW
IS THE CHANCELLOR'S OFF LIKE YOU
DON'T NECESSARY SAY IT WASN'T
THE RIGHT SAME COURSE YOU SAID
IT'S A DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE SO I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT DEFINITION THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
IS USING TO DEFINE WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S THE SAME COURSE BECAUSE
A MEAN CERTAINLY THERE WAS
APPROVAL FOR IT BUT THERE WAS.
ALSO VERY CLEAR INTENT OF WHERE
WE WANTED TO GO AND I THINK THIS
NEW WANTS CAN ACTUALLY -- MAKE
US RETHINK ABOUT WHETHER THE
INTENT IS BEING MET OR NOT.
IT CAN BE DEFINED.
IN ANY LEGAL WHERE WHICH WAY BUT
AGAIN A THINK FOR THOSE OF US
THAT WERE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
LAST YEAR THAT.
WE WERE VERY CLEAR.
YEAH BUT IT'S I WOULD SAY FROM --
YOU KNOW THE STATUTE DOESN'T
INCLUDE A STANDARD SO I THINK
THE COMMITMENT WE NEED TO MAKE
THIS TO YOU ALL INTO OUR
COLLEGES THAT WE'RE NOT BUILDING
A COLLEGE THAT -- THAT IS GOING
TO COMPETE FOR STUDENTS.
ABOUT THEIR ALSO SERVING AND SO
I WOULD SAY THE VERY CLEAR LINE
AS I'VE UNDERSTOOD IT BUT I
THINK -- YOU KNOW IF THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE WE WILL COME BACK AND
TELL YOU IS THE COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION -- THAT IT IS EITHER
DIFFERENT FIELDS ALL TOGETHER OR
THE DELIVERY IN COP AS A
COMPETENCY BASED -- FORM OF
LEARNING -- IS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT IS OFFERED AT OTHER
COLLEGES [inaudible]
SO.
YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING IF YOU
CAN FIND A WORK AROUND TO
OFFERING THE SAME COURSE BECAUSE
IT'S SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE AND THAT'S WHAT THE
IT MEETS THE CRITERIA BUT I WANT
TO JUST BE VERY SPECIFIC BUT AS
I UNDERSTAND.
THE CONVERSATIONS IT IS SPEND
THAT IS IT IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE
IT IS OFFERED AS COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION AND THAT'S WHY
BY THE LEADERSHIP AND AS A
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE WERE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING OFFERED BY THE BY
THEIR LIKE COLLEGE.
IF I MAY UM THE FIRST PROGRAM
AND AND THAT'S WHY I ACTUALLY
WENT INTO THE DETAIL OF MEDICAL
CODING IS CHANGING AS A WHOLE
CAREER AN OPTION.
THAT ACTUALLY WAS SELECTED PRIOR
TO MY BEING -- HIRED IT WAS
SELECTED BECAUSE IT WAS -- MOST
POPULAR WITH SCA USE MEMBERSHIP
THEY CONSIDER THOSE WELL PAYING
JOBS THAT THEY WANTED TO GET THE
SKILLS AND TRAINING IN AND WE
WANTED A FREE OFFERING THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY COUNTER.
THE FOR PROFITS WERE CHARGING
PEOPLE TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST
TO LEARN TO BE MEDICAL CODERS
AND THEY'LL NEVER GET OUT FROM
UNDER THAT DEBT -- SO THAT WAS
MY UNDERSTANDING OF ABOUT THE
ORIGIN I WILL SPEAK FROM -- MY
THIRTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE BOTH
IN EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THAT HAVING
CONFIDENCE IN SEAT COMPETENCY
BASED TRAINING THAT IS SPECIFIC
TO THE HARD FUNCTIONAL SOFT
SKILLS.
REQUIRED TO DO THAT JOB IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE MEDICAL
CODING CURRICULA -- IT CURRICULA
EXPERIENCE THAT ONE ONE GET A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT
THAT QUESTION I MEAN THAT WAS AN
EXAMPLE THAT WAS THAT WAS
DISCUSSED LAST YEAR -- THAT VERY
CLEARLY BUT I THINK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THERE LOOK THERE'S NO
SURPRISE THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
DIDN'T NECESSARILY LOVE THIS
PROPOSAL AND I MEAN THAT THIS IS
NOT A SECRET AND SO I THINK THAT
AS THE PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD
THIS IS AN AND I GOTCHA GAME NO
ONE TRIED WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT REALLY HAPPENED
THAT IS PART.
OF THE ROLE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PLEASE -- AND SO I DON'T THINK
THIS IS ABOUT ANYONE.
YOU KNOW WANTING TO DO SOMETHING
WRONG OR GOING EAST AS WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND AND I THINK THESE
POINTED QUESTIONS HELP US
UNDERSTAND -- WE WERE ALREADY
SKEPTICAL ABOUT THIS AS A
LEGISLATURE ON WHETHER THIS WAS
THE RIGHT MOVE OR NOT -- AND I
SUSPECT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ASK THIS LEVEL OF
QUESTION -- AS A WAY TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER OUR SKEPTIC
IT'S A SKEPTICISM WAS EIGHT YOU
KNOW IT MERITED OR NOT AND IF
IT'S NOT IT'S GREAT LIKE IF IT'S
IF IF WE FIND.
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY A BETTER
PATH TO MOVE FORWARD IN AND WE
ARE REALLY LIKING IT I THINK
THAT'S GREAT WE'RE NOT THERE YET --
I WOULD SAY I DON'T KNOW I'M
LOOKING AT THE CHAIR BUT I COULD
BE A LOAN IN THIS MAYBE IT'S
JUST ME -- BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS
THEY SENSE SLIGHT DEFENSIVENESS
AND I THINK IT'S MORE A SENSE OF
REALLY TRYING TO ASK I KNOW
THERE HARD QUESTIONS I KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW ALL THE ANSWERS.
BUT I HAVE A THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO JUST ASK THEM --
AND INTO UNDERSTAND WHERE WE'RE
AT SO THAT WE CAN ALSO WE ALL GO
BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
TO TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS.
AND SO I THINK THE MORE
INFORMATION WE HAVE THE BETTER.
AND I HOPE I WOULD JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT I I HOPE YOU DON'T
CENTS DEFENSIVENESS FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I WOULD JUST
SAY -- YOU KNOW I THINK LIKE WE
DO WITH OTHER COLLEGES WE YOU
KNOW THE THE WORK OF THE ONLINE
COLLEGES BEING HANDLED BY THE
DISTRICT LED BY A BOARD OF
TRUSTEES -- BUT I DO THINK THAT
AND I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT I'M.
WITH YOU KNOW THERE IS A SET OF
STATUTES THAT WE EXPECT THE
ONLINE COLLEGE TO COMPLY WITH
THERE ARE ALSO WE KNOW
COMMITMENTS THAT WE MADE TO
OTHER COLLEGES IN OUR SYSTEM AND
DO YOU ALL THAT WE WILL -- YOU
KNOW THAT WE INTEND TO BE A
VOICE AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
COLLEGES LEADERSHIP UNDERSTANDS
THAT THOSE COMMITMENTS WERE MADE.
WELL I THINK THE ISSUE IS IN
ABOUT TEN MINUTES WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT HOW STUDENTS ARE.
SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS AND
THEY'RE HUNGRY YEAH AND WE HAVE
A PROGRAM HERE THAT NOT A LOT OF
US LIKE WE COULD EASILY TAKE A
MOTION AND ELIMINATE THIS
PROGRAM WITHIN THIRTY SECONDS
THERE'S NOT MUCH OF A DESIRE TO
HAVE THIS BUT THE PRIOR GOVERNOR.
WAS INTERESTED IN THIS CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION HAVE HEARD WHEN
WHERE THE OTHER ANOTHER
CHANCELLOR REALLY LIKES THIS BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF SKEPTICISM AND
WE'RE KIND OF GOING.
ON A WIN HERE SO -- IF WE DID
CONTINUE THIS WIN WOULD WITH
WHEN WHEN DO YOU THINK THAT WE
BE REASSURED THAT THIS IS A
WORTHWHILE INVESTMENTS WHEN WE
COULD EASILY -- REDIRECT THESE
MONIES AND HELP STUDENTS BE ABLE.
TO EAT TODAY AS OPPOSED TO GO
HUNGRY WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
CLASS YEAH THEY'RE THEY'RE EIGHT
BETWEEN EIGHT AND TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE WORKING
THREE AND FOUR JOBS AND THEY
STILL CAN'T EAT PROPERLY.
NOR CAN THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY AND
SO I THINK THAT THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO GET BETTER JOBS.
AND I NO NO NO NO I I YEAH A
LITTLE WE SEE SIX DEL OCTOBER
ONE IS WHEN OUR FIRST TRAINING
PROGRAMS GO LIVE.
AND I THINK -- THAT YOU'LL NEED
AT LEAST THROUGH THE END OF THE
YEAR TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS THROUGH
THOSE TRAINING PROGRAMS AND WHAT
OTHER PROGRAMS WE ARE STARTING
TO CREATE AND DEVELOP WITH OTHER
EMPLOYERS.
IT I MEAN YOU KNOW.
I THINK YOU WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING ACTUALLY THERE TO HAVE.
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ISSUE WITH
THE OR TO APPRECIATE THAT IT'S
CONTRIBUTING SOMETHING TO THE
MINISTER SERLING WEEK I MEAN
THERE ARE THERE ARE OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT WE ARE NOT.
PROPERLY RUNNING AND ARE AS A
BIG LINE.
OUTSIDE THE DOOR A LOOKING -- TO
LOOK LOOK AT EXPENDITURES IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SOME THIS
IS A ELEMENT AND I'M -- YOU
YOU'VE HEARD FROM -- FROM --
BOTH PARTIES BOTH HOUSES AS FAR
AS UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THESE --
ABOUT THESE ENDEAVORS GOING
FORWARD SO WE'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT.
OKAY -- HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE BASIC NEEDS.
I AM GONNA START US OFF AND I AM
SHOWING BY MY COLLEAGUE CALLING
CANLEY WHO IS.
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR OFFICES WORK
ON ISSUES LIKE BASIC NEEDS
MENTAL HEALTH AND AND OTHER
PRESSING ISSUES OUR STUDENTS
SPACE -- I'M STARTING ON PAGE
FOURTEEN OF THE HAND OUT.
BY THE SAME POWER POINT -- DECK
THAT WE SHARE EARLIER I THINK
JUST TO KIND OF PUT THIS.
RECESSION IN CONTEXT OF THE HOPE
CENTER FOR COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND
JUSTICE DID A SURVEY -- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR OFFICE LAST
YEAR -- FAILED THAT HALF OF A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
RESPONDED TO THE SURVEY WERE
FOOD IN SECURING THE PRIOR
THIRTY DAYS 60% WERE HOUSING AND
SECURED 19% WERE HOMELESS IN THE
PRIOR YEAR.
AND SO AS YOU MENTIONED MISTER
CHAIR I THINK THIS IS A AND
ESPECIALLY PRESSING ISSUE FOR US
TO CONSIDER HOW TO WE SUPPORT --
STUDENT SUCCESS WHILE OUR
STUDENTS ARE FACING --
CHALLENGES REGARDING THEIR BASIC
BOTTOM OF PAGE.
FOURTEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR HAVE TAKEN ACTIONS --
ON RELATED ISSUES IN RECENT
YEARS -- PROPERTY IN TWO AND A
HALF MILLION AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TEN MILLION IN --
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE CONDUCTED A
SURVEY OF HOW COLLEGES ARE USING
THOSE FUNDS A HUNDRED THIRTEEN
COLLEGES HAVE A FOOD PANTRY OR
OTHER -- FORMS A FEW
DISTRIBUTION ON CAMPUS SEVENTY
THREE COLLEGES PROVIDE CAL FRESH.
INFORMATION SYSTEMATICALLY SIXTY
COLLEGES HAVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
CAL FRESH STAFF TO ASSIST
STUDENTS WITH THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
BOB JUST MAYBE KIND OF GOING TO
THE NEXT PAGE LOOKING AT A KIND
OF A BROADER VIEW WE THINK
COLLEGES HAVE AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN -- AND HELPING STUDENTS --
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS OUR
STUDENTS ARE PART COLLEGES CAN
USE THEIR STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA RESOURCES
STUDENT EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM RESOURCES AND AS WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
THERE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
GRANT FUNDS TO SUPPORT THESE.
BOB I FIX WHAT WE WOULD ARGUE IS
THAT THERE IS A SYSTEMATIC
PROBLEM THOUGH -- THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS PRIMARILY TO THE
FINANCIAL AID THAT'S NECESSARY --
TO TO COVER THE TRUE COST OF
COLLEGE.
WE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR WORK ON FINANCIAL AID
REFORM IF YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE FIFTEEN WE HAVE A BILL
THAT WERE SPONSORING SB TWO
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR LEYVA.
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
THAT GETS SQUARELY UP THIS
PROBLEM OF DRESSING AT THE TRUE
COST OF ATTENDANCE NOT ONLY
TUITION BUT ALSO FOOD HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION OTHER COSTS THAT
STUDENTS SPACE.
WHILE THEY'RE GOING TO COLLEGE
IF YOU LOOK ON THE RIGHT --
UNDER SB TWO NINETY ONE THE
STUDENTS FINANCIAL AID WOULD BE
CALCULATED BY LOOKING UP AT TRUE
COSTS THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE SUBTRACTING OUT WHAT
WE EXPECT THE STUDENT FAMILY TO
PAY.
SUBTRACTING OUT WHAT WE THINK.
WITH THE STUDENT ALREADY
RECEIVED ANOTHER GRANTED -- THAT
WOULD BE A NEW GRAD CREATED BY
THE THE NEW FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM.
SO OUR REQUEST FOR THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD BE TO SUPPORT SB TWO
NINETY ONE FOR OTHER LEGISLATION
THAT DOES US -- BUT IT CHIEF THE
SIMILAR GOAL.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IN TERMS
OF A BUDGET REQUEST IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN --
NINETEEN TWENTY THE THE OTHER
HAND OUT THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE IT
CLOSES -- IS OUR PRELIMINARY
REPORT ON THE BASIC NEEDS
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED IN
RECENT YEARS.
AND I AM BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
WE DO KNOW THAT WE HAVE AN
ASSEMBLY BILL I DOES THAT A SONG.
AND THIS IS ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
RIGHT THE SO WE WE SAW THE BILL
TODAY MEDINA IS BILL LONG WITH --
MISTER MCCARTY HERE SO WE CAN
YOU CAN PROPERLY SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY BILL THE HAS THE EXACT
SAME LANGUAGE AS THIS.
AS THE SENATE BILL PLUS OUR BILL
HELPS UC CSU STUDENTS SO WE'RE
CURRENTLY REVIEWING WE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
FINANCIAL AID REFORM -- THERE
ARE PRINCIPLES THAT WE THINK ARE
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE --
YOU KNOW BE I WOULD JUST NOTICE
I THINK IT'S IT'S NOT THE SAME
LANGUAGE I RECOGNIZE ECHOES --
IT IT REFORMS THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM IN A BROADER WAY I THINK
WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE THINK ABOUT THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE WERE DEFINING
TOTAL COST IN SIMILAR WAYS.
THAT WE'RE COVERING SIMILAR
GROUPS OF STUDENTS -- IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO US.
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS --
BUT ATTENDED -- WITH A CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION GOAL THAT
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS ARE TREATED SIMILARLY
UNDER -- UNDER A REVISED
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM AND SO I
WOULD SAY WE ARE HAPPY -- TO TO
SUPPORT LEGISLATION THAT.
INCLUDING YOURS THAT MEETS THOSE
PRINCIPLES AND I WOULD -- YOU
KNOW I THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT
THAT AND HOW DO WE ACCOMPLISH
WHAT WE NEED TO IN THIS BUDGET
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL.
RECOGNIZE THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS UNDER CURRENT FINANCIAL
AID STRUCTURE ARE TREATED THE
MOST INEQUITABLE ACROSS SEGMENTS
YEAH WE CONCUR WITH THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE LA CHANCELLOR.
AN HOUR AGO.
THAT OVER 90% OF THE COSTS FOR
COMMUNITY CALLED STUDENT.
IS A NON TUITION AND SO THAT'S
THE FINANCIAL AID PIECE THAT
THAT JUST DOESN'T.
ADDRESS THAT POPULATION SO BUT I
WOULD JUST EITHER WAY WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT AND I
WOULD ARGUE IT'S BOTH NOT JUST
THE BENEFIT LEVEL NOT THE HOW
MUCH EACH STATE WOULD RECEIVE
BUT ALSO THE ELIGIBILITY THAT OF
YOU KNOW WE OFTEN SAY HALF OF
STUDENTS RECEIVE.
A COLLEGE PROMISE GRANTS ALL
LESS THAN 5% RECEIVE CAL GRANTS
BECAUSE CAL GRANTS TODAY SAY IN
ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE YOU NEED TO
ENTER COLLEGE NO MORE THAN ONE
YEAR AFTER HIGH SCHOOL AND SO
CALM.
SO I THINK ONLY INCREASING THE
BENEFIT LEVEL FOR CURRENT CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS DOESN'T TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THAT MOST OF OUR
NEEDY STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVE THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PIECES OF OUR PROPOSAL TODAY.
GET RID OF THAT H..
ARBITRARY AGE CAP [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY -- YES SO THESE ARE ALL
OBVIOUSLY OTHER -- ISSUES THAT --
WE WANT TO ADDRESS AS FAR
FOCUSING ON OTHER THAN THE TRUE
REALITIES OF COLLEGE STUDENTS --
IT'S AS HEARTBREAKING TO READ
THE STORIES ABOUT STUDENTS
SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS AND AND
NOT HAVING -- ADEQUATE FOOD TO
FOCUS ON THEIR STUDY SO.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE EVER
[inaudible]
NOW.
OKAY HI THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE'RE GOING -- TO CERTAINLY
MONITOR WE WERE YOU KNOW
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSALS.
IN THE BUDGET FOR THE OTHER
SEGMENTS AND YOU KNOW SUB
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GONNA LOOK
AT FOR THE COMMUNICATIONS FINAL
BUDGET GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU -- WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT BEFORE THAT
WE CAN DO THE ADD ONS FOR THE
ONE ACCIDENT TODAY THIS IS THE
APPROVING.
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY.
PROPOSALS IN ADDITION.
THE THE THE ITEMS OUTLINES WE'RE
GOING TO ADD ON IN THE IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- THE GENDER PACKAGE
[inaudible]
MR MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
SIR BRO [inaudible]
OKAY.
WITH THAT WILL PROCEED WITH OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
THIS YEAR'S.
GOOD MORNING MY VALLEY KINCAID
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND WE'RE
GLAD WITH OUR WITH THE
CONVERSATION TODAY ADDRESSING
BASIC NEEDS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AS THE HOPE CENTER SURVEY
REVEALED 50% AND 60% OF STUDENTS
RESPECTIVELY ARE FACING FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURITY.
AND WE NEED STOP GAP MEASURES
REAL FINANCIAL AID REFORM AND A
STATE COMMITMENT TO DO SURVEYS
LIKE THESE TO REGULARLY LIFT UP
BARRIERS FACED.
BY OUR FIRST GENERATION LOW
INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
THIS COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LAURA AS ABA
CUBITS WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
OUR ANALYSES HAVE FOUND THAT DO
DIA HI NON TUITION COSTS AND
INSUFFICIENT NEED BASED
FINANCIAL AID COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CAN BE LESS AFFORDABLE FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THAN PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN THE SAME REGION.
AND AT SEVERAL COLLEGES THE
STUDENTS MAY HAVE TO WORK MORE
THAN THIRTY HOURS PER WEEK TO
COVER NOT COSTS.
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS
WITH FINANCIAL NEED HAVE ALWAYS
HAD THEIR FEES WAIVED WITH OVER
90% OF STUDENTS COLLEGE COSTS
BEYOND TUITION AND FEES.
AND AS WE'VE JUST HEARD HIGH
SHARES OF STUDENTS REPORTING
BOTH FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATIVE FLEXIBILITY THAT
ALLOWS COLLEGES TO HELP NEEDY
STUDENTS BETTER COVER NON
TUITION COSTS AS THIRTY SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY DO WITH THE COLLEGE
PROMISE.
THIS IS INTEGRAL TO IMPROVING
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND REDUCING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS TWO OF THE KEY
LEGISLATIVE INTENSE OF THE
ORIGINAL PROMISE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
OUR IS IT AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TAKINGTHE ACTION
THAT YOU JUST TOOK TO APPROVE.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY ITEM -- WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT YOU SHOULD BE
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SPENDING
PLAN WE ALSO ECHOED THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
REGARDING HOW DISTRICTS ARE
CONFUSED BY THESE TWO COMPETING
STANDARDS.
AND TO WHICH PRIORITY THE
PROJECTS ARE BEING EVALUATED
WHEN VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION
FIFTY ONE THAT THEY APPROVE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR MORE THAN
JUST HEALTH AND SAFETY PROJECTS.
FOR CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION
RECONSTRUCTION AND EQUIPPING OF
IMPORTANT FACILITIES -- THE
DELAY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE DOES MAKE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR COLLEGES
TO PLAN.
THEIR BOND PROGRAMS AND THEIR
PROJECTS AND WE DON'T SEE A GOOD
POLICY REASON WHEN THE DEMAND IS
THERE TO DELAY PROP.
FIFTY ONE ULTIMATELY FACILITIES
ARE VERY IMPORTANT IN MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS OTHER
PRIORITIES INCLUDING STUDENT
SUCCESS INCREASING ACCESS TO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOUR SPEECH ON CAPITAL
OUTLAY REMINDING ME THAT WE NEED
TO ADD ON I MISTER GALLAGHER TO
THE VOTE THERE FOR PROP FIFTY
ONE CAP LOUDLY.
THIS CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
OKAY THANK YOU.
HELLO KATRINA LINDA WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WE SUPPORT THE CONTINUED FOR
LIMITATION THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA.
WE NEED A FINANCING METHOD FOR
COLLEGES THAT REFLECT STATE
PRIORITIES AROUND ACCESS ALSO
STUDENT SUCCESS IN EQUITY.
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS ALREADY IN
PLACE TO ENSURE COLLEGES DO NOT
CREATE LOW VALUE CREDENTIALS OR
WAR DUPLICATE AGREES.
WE ALSO DO BELIEVE THERE IS A
PREMIUM VALUE TO THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER WHICH HAS
HELPED THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING GRADUATE IN A MORE
TIMELY AND AFFORDABLE MEANS AN
OTHERWISE.
THE NEW FINING FORMALIZE A
FINANCIAL EXTENSION OF THE
STUDENT CENTERED APPROACH
OUTLINED IN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS ADOPTED FOR COLLEGES.
AND WE URGE THAT YOU REMAIN
COMMITTED TO ITS IMPLEMENTATION
THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY -- I SAID THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND
THIS -- JOIN ANY HEARING.
AND I LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE. FOR THAT SB TWO
NINETY ONE APPROVAL IT -- I'M A
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE MYSELF.
AND ALSO PART OF THE YES YOU
[inaudible]
SEC.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERM MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DOLLARS
DAVIS AND VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
ECONOMIC CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WELL THE ECONOMICS AND FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CONTINUES TO OPPOSE PERFORMANCE
SPACE FUNDING WE HAVE PROPOSED
SEVERAL AREAS WHERE WE BELIEVE
THAT THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA.
CAN BE AMENDED TO BETTER SERVE
OUR STUDENTS BY HOLDING
PERFORMANCE SPACE FUNDING AT 10%
ONLY COUNTING A STUDENTS HIGHEST
AWARD ANNUALLY.
AND LEVELING ALL ASSOCIATES
DEGREES WITH THE SAME POINT
TOTAL WE BELIEVE THAT SOME OF
THE GREATEST CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STUDENT SUCCESS FUNDING FORMULA
WILL BE AMELIORATED TO A DEGREE.
WE ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ASSEMBLY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE THE ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES THEY ALL
DESERVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DEAN MARCOM A PERSONAL
THOSE SERVICE CALLS FEDERATION
TEACHERS I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
A COUPLE THINGS.
ONE IS THE THREE AND TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL IN THE
FUNDING FORMULA.
AND THE STUDENT -- THE SINCE
EXCESS PART OF IT.
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING DOES
NOT WORK.
NUMBER ONE ALL THE TWEAKS AND
ALL THE CHANGES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE IS GOING ON DOESN'T ADDRESS
TO SHORTFALL AT ALL IT'S NOT
GOING TO DRESS.
ANYTHING THIS THIS DEMONSTRATES
HOW POORLY CONCEIVED AND PUT
TOGETHER THIS FUNDING FOR IT WAS
PUT TOGETHER IN THE FIRST PLACE.
PERSONALLY I THINK WE SHOULD GET
RID OF THIS PART OF THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE FUNDING.
THE OTHER PART OF IT IS THAT.
YOU KNOW YES IN TERMS OF OUR
STUDENTS -- LIKE WE SAID FROM
NOW -- HOPE OF THE HOPE OF LAB --
STUDY.
HOW FOR STUDENTS ARE THE FOOD
INSECURE ARE ARE HOMELESS OR
HOME INSECURE?
THAT REPRESENT A LOS REALISM OR
I I TEACH OVER FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
ACROSS THE STATE THAT REPRESENTS
OVER A MILLION STUDENTS.
THERE EITHER FOLK FOOD INSECURE
OUR HOME IS SECURE THAT IS A
PERVASIVE TREMENDOUS PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE THAT WE NEED TO
FACE.
BECAUSE THESE ARE CRITICAL BEARS
JUSTIN SUCCESS I DON'T CARE HOW
WHAT KIND OF PATH FOR YOU HAVE
IF YOU CAN'T EAT YOU DON'T HAVE
A HOME YOU'RE TALKING THIS
SUCCESSFUL AND AND COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS VERY SERIOUSLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
PATRICK CALUMET THE MCCALLUM
GROUP REPRESENTING YOU BECOME
ANY CALLS DISTRICT LA CA BECAUSE
DISTRICT KELLY COLLEGE GUILD.
WE REPRESENT EIGHT OTHER COMING
BECAUSE DISTRICT FOR WORKING
WITH THE COALITION OF FACTLY
GROUP'S FAQ.
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES THE LA
COLLEGE KILLED.
KEY POINTS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOKING AT YOUR FINANCIAL AID
PROPOSAL THAT'S A HUGE NEED FOR
OUR STUDENTS HAS BEEN SAID.
PROPERTY TAX WE'VE BEEN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
YOU ADOPT THE BUDGET AND THERE'S
NO GUARANTEE THE PROPERTY TAX
COMES IN WE NEED TO FIX THAT AND
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
FIX THAT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
THE PERFORMANCE FUNDING FORMULA
PUT INTO PLACE WE THOUGHT WHAT
THE COMMITTEE DID LAST YEAR WAS
THE RIGHT WAY TO GO ON IT.
NOT THE WAY IT WAS.
PUT TOGETHER BUT TO CRITICAL
PIECES ONE IS IT DOESN'T COUNT
ON POVERTY BOB WAIVERS BY
COLLEGE IT DOES MY DISTRICT FOR
YOU BUT DISTRICT LA ANOTHER
DISTRICTS THAT NEED TO BE FIXED.
IT DIDN'T ADDRESSED NON CREDIT
NOT CREDIT IS WHERE WE DO OUR C.
T. T. E. S. L. WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL ON THAT. FOR DREAM
CENTERS WE WOULD LIKE TO IT USED
TO PUT SOMEONE TIME FUNNY INTO
IT.
AND OPEN IT UP FOR LGBT STUDENTS
SO.
PLACES LIKE LA VALLEY COLLEGE
THE ONE TO BRING VETERANS LGBT
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE MORE
SERVICES THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KYLE PATEL AND
I'M A THIRD YEAR STUDENT AT DE
ANZA COLLEGE -- I'M HERE TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY SOME OF MY
EXPERIENCES AND WHY I BELIEVE
THAT PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
IS DETRIMENTAL TO COMMUNITIES
AND ALIENATES THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BASE.
SO A BIT OF AN ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE OF FIRST ON OVER A DE
ANZA COLLEGE WE'RE CURRENTLY
HAVING A LOT OF COURSE SHORTAGES.
AND WERE IS SEEING INSTRUCTORS
ADDING STUDENTS PACKED UP TO
BUILDING CAPACITY JUST TO ENSURE
THAT SOME OF THEM CAN MAKE IT
INTO THEIR OUT TO YOUR TRANSFER
DEADLINE.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE ALL THE
STUDENTS SO THERE ARE A LOT
BEING LEFT BEHIND.
ON THESE STUDENTS THERE ARE
PARENTS ARE SERVICE WORKERS ARE
VETERANS AND THEIR RETURNING
PROFESSIONALS TO HELP STAY
CURRENT ON THEIR INTEREST IN
THEIR INDUSTRIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI KEVIN RITCHIE DANS A COLLEGE --
IT AGAIN ON PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING IT SURE -- SERVES TO
TRYING CREATE THIS VISION OF AN
IDEA OF A UNREALISTIC COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT FITS A PERFECT
MOLD OF BEING EIGHTEEN FRESH AT
A HIGH SCHOOL BEING SUPPORTED BY
THEIR FAMILY GOING STRAIGHT TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF BEING
PUSHED OUT IN TWO YEARS -- AS
MUCH AS WE MIGHT WANT TO DO THAT
NOT EVERYONE HAS THE LIBERTY OR
PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE.
TO GO THROUGH SUCH AN EXPERIENCE --
MANY OF US HAVE TO SUPPORT
OURSELVES WITH THE JOBS OR HAVE
OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES THAT MAY
TAKE A MAY TAKE PRECEDENT OVER
SCHOOL AT THAT TIME.
SO A PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
IS CLEARLY NOT IDEAL FOR OUR
SITUATIONS AND NEEDS TO BE
COMPLETELY ABOLISHED NOR.
TO IN ORDER -- TO IT
[inaudible]
SORRY -- WE WE DO ASK THAT YOU
COMPLETELY ABOLISHED FORMS FACE
FUNDING SO YOU MAY -- ASSIST ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT AND THAT MAY
NEED THIS ASSISTANCE.
THANK.
HELLO I AND MICHELLE HA I AM A
STUDENT FROM THE ENDS AS WELL.
A PRIME EXAMPLE OF A COLLEGE
THAT THIS PERFORMANCE SPACE
FINDING WITH THAT FACT -- SO
WHERE IN THE HEART OF THE
SILICON VALLEY THERE'S A LOT OF
STUDENTS AND THERE IS A LOT OF
SUCCESSAT THE END SO -- WE ARE
TALKING TRANSFERS AND WE'RE
SENDING STUDENTS THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS OF COLLEGES.
BUT EVEN THEN.
A LOT OF MY FRIENDS MY CLOSE
FRIENDS ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP
UP WITH THEIR CLASSES BECAUSE
THERE'S SUCH A SHORTAGE
ESPECIALLY FIRST IMAGES THEY
CAN'T GET OUT IN THE TWO YEARS.
THEY CAN'T GET THE CERTIFICATE
TIME LIKE WE SAID THERE'S A LOT
OF PROBLEMS WITH AWARDING
FINDING BASED ON CERTIFICATES
AND TRANSFER.
BUT I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES VISION.
AND WE'RE HERE TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND JUST THAT TRADITIONAL
STUDENT.
IS NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF ALL THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS LIKE
THEY HAVE SAID THERE'S SO MANY
MORE.
OF THEM AND I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S RIGHT.
SERRA AWARD STUDENTS WHO ARE
DOING WELL.
AND NOT REWARDING STUDENTS WHO
NEED IT THE MOST AND IT'S BIG
EQUITY ISSUE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA MUSCAT I'M HERE WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
MUST A COUNSELOR AND COMMUNICATE
WHICH SOME HERE BECAUSE I HOPE
THAT LEGISLATOR ALSO CONSIDERS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING -- FOR HOW WE
CAN ADDRESS THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A A LACK OF DIVERSITY AMONG
OUR FACULTY.
LINE EXPERIENCE MAKE UP AT LEAST
HALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LESS THAN.
FOURTEEN OF PROFESSORS AND
FACULTY OUR LAND NEXT MY COUNT
MYSELF AMONG THAT GROUP SO I
HOPE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT ALLOCATION AND FINDING.
A FOR MORE IMPLICIT RACIAL BIAS
TRAINING AS WELL AS THE
MENTORING OF DIVERSE FACULTY AND
RECRUITMENT THANK YOU.
GOODAFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA HE
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL EDUCATION.
BOTH THE ANALYSIS AND THE
TESTIMONY NOTED THAT THE FUNDING
FORMULA SHORTFALL ANOTHER
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ARE
RESULTS.
OF LAST YEAR'S ADOPTION OF THE
FUNDING FORMULA.
KERR EDUCATION PROGRAMS OF SOME
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE PROGRAMS
IN OUR COLLEGES BECAUSE OF
TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO
CHANGES IN THE MARKET.
IT'S FOR THIS REASON THAT IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING A FULL FUNDING OF
STRONG WORK FORCE IN UNDER AND
ON GOING FUNDING.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNICATES DISTRICT.
WE APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
THE FUNDING FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
FOR THE SADDLEBACK COLLEGE --
PROJECTS AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION TO
INCLUDE THE REST OF THE PROJECTS
I ALSO -- ENCOMPASS IRVINE
VALLEY COLLEGES.
PROJECT -- AS WELL AS ON BEHALF
OF PASADENA CITY COLLEGE --
INITIALLY THERE WAS A PROJECT I
WAS INCLUDED IN THE CAPITAL OUT
WAY APPROVED PROJECTS -- BACK IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
STATE.
HOWEVER -- OVER TIME -- THE
BUILDING WAS EVENTUALLY --
CONDEMNED BY THE STATE AND
REQUIRED RETROFITTING -- ALL
MAINLY -- FOR SEISMIC CAPACITY
IN ACTIVITY -- HOWEVER OVER TIME
THE THE STATE'S.
COMMITMENT TO FINDING IT HAS
KIND OF DISAPPEARED DISSIPATED
IN ALMOST DISAPPEARED -- SO WE
APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION TO RE INCLUDE
THAT PROJECT AND THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THAT PROJECT
INTO -- THE BUDGET FOR THIS YEAR
THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIR -- THIS EXALTED BRIAN
HOW AT THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS -- JUST WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT YEAH EVEN AFTER
ALMOST A YEAR LATER AT THE
FUNDING FORMULA CONTINUES TO
HAVE PROBLEMS AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO ME THIS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
FACULTY MEMBERS LAST YEAR.
NOW WITH THIS ALONG WITH THE
STUDENT BODY HAVE.
CONSISTENTLY ACOSTA LEE OPPOSED --
THIS PROPOSAL -- THIS COMMITTEE --
REJECTED IT I MEAN I'VE NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING.
IN MY LIFE I'M AND I HAVE NEARLY
TWO DECADES OF EXPERIENCE DOING --
WORK IN A PUBLIC POLICY
SACRAMENTO I'VE NEVER SEEN SUCH
PROCESS THAT WAS SO FLAWED. TO
BEGIN WITH -- IS SO UNFAIR AND
JOSH -- AND YOU KNOW WE HEARD
FROM TESTIMONY TODAY THAT IT
CONTINUES TO HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THIS OUTCOME BASED --
METRIC DOES NOT WORK I IT IS NOT
GOOD FOR STUDENTS DOC OF A
FACULTY STOCK OF FOR COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
SO -- IF WE REALLY WANT TO
INVEST -- IN STUDENT SUCCESS WE
TO PUT THE MONEY WHERE IT REALLY
MATTERS LIKE FULL TIME HIRING
MORE FULL TIME FACT HIRING.
AS WELL AS THE ON INVESTING MORE
MONEY FOR THE PART TIME FACULTY
OFFICE HOURS THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE EFFECTIVE IN THE WORK --
SO PLEASE CONSIDER.
YOU KNOW I I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
HOPEFULLY WITH THE SENATE.
OVER THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THE FUTURE -- TO COMPLETELY ON
DOING THE ON OUTCOMES BASED
METRICS AND ONE MORE THING --
THE OTHER LEGISLATION THAT'S
CANCERS.
OFFICE REFER -- TO FOR FOR TO TO
HELP IN OTHER STUDENTS AB NINE
FORTY THREE WHICH WE ARE PROP CO
SPONSORS OF IT'S A BILL THAT.
ASSEMBLYMAN DAVID CHIU IS
OFFERING -- IT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY HELP OR SEE A POTTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
EVAN HAWKINS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I LIKE THIS
COMMITTEE FAQ OPPOSED THE
FUNDING FORMULA LAST YEAR AND WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THE
PERFORMANCE SPACE FUNDING IS NOT
THE ANSWER FOR OUR STUDENTS
WE'VE SEEN THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
INACTION MANY OF WHICH ARE LAID
OUT IN THE ANALYSIS AND WE SEEN
OUTCOMES THAT ARE VALUABLE FOR
METRICS AN EXTRA REVENUE -- BUT
NOT NECESSARILY VALUABLE FILLERS
FOR OUR STUDENTS WE TRULY WANT
TO IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS THEN
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THE FACULTY
THAT CHANGE LIVES AND AND
QUICKLY REGARDING THE ONLINE
COLLEGE WHICH WE ALSO POSE LAST
YEAR.
WE SHARE MANY OF THE CONCERNS
LAID OUT IN THE ANALYSIS OUR
MEMBERS ARE DEEPLY TROUBLED BY
THE EXORBITANT SALARIES IN THE
NO BID CONTRACT TO AN EXECUTIVE
RECRUITER THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER I ALSO INSTITUTING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AN ACADEMIC SENATE WITHIN THE ON
MY COLLEGE NEEDS TO BE A MUCH
HIGHER PRIORITY THE REMAINS A
LOT OF QUESTIONS THERE IS WELL
ULTIMATELY WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES AVAILABLE WE DON'T
BELIEVE IN OVER BUDGETED AND BE
DONE IN COLLEGE IS THE BEST
INVESTMENT.
WHEN THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT NEED FUNDING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU?
NICOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF LOS
RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE AND LONG
BEACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ADOPTION OF THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION FOR THAT CAPITAL
OUTLAY PLAN -- WE ALSO LIKE TO
URGE THE COMMITTEES ADOPTION OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA%
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
THIS IS -- MICHELLE UNDERWOOD --
I AM HERE TO YOU KNOW REMIND YOU
THAT WE ARE IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE FUN FORMULA --
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SHORTFALL AND THAT WAS DISCUSSED
TODAY WE'RE DEFINITELY LOOKING
FORWARD TO REVISED INFORMATION --
IN MAY WE THINK IT SETS A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT TO NOT FULLY
FUND -- THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA AND THE FIRST
YEAR WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN.
THERE'S ALREADY ENOUGH
UNCERTAINTY AS FOLKS ARE
IMPLEMENTING THIS NEW FUNDING
FORMULA AND WE THINK IT'S KEY --
THAT THE STATE -- EXCEPT
COMMITMENT TO FULLY FUND IT WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ACTION TODAY ON A PROPOSITION
FIFTY ONE FUNDS -- WE ARE FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF FUNDING ALL THE
PROJECTS APPROVED BY THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS.
AND THEN FINALLY ON FINANCIAL
AID WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM TO ADD A SECOND YEAR --
WE ALSO DO SUPPORT -- OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT LOOK AT MORE THAN
NEEDS BASED -- FINANCIALLY TO
STEM -- LIKE THE ONE THAT CENTER
LEYVA IS PROPOSING THANK YOU.
CHEN MCCARTY AND AND MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ACTION TODAY TO SUPPORT FUNDING
ALL FACILITIES PROJECTS INCLUDED
IN THE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT
AND WE HOPE THAT MOVING FORWARD
YOU DON'T ACCEPT A BUDGET.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE FUNDING IN
THE WE HONOR THE WILL OF
CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS AND ADDRESS
THE COST ESCALATION -- BY
DELAYING THESE PROJECTS -- INNER
LETTER WE'VE PROVIDED -- I SET
OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
SENSIBLE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA.
ON THAT WE THINK WILL HELP TO
LEAD TO MORE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION -- INCLUDING --
FUNDING -- HIGHER BASE.
I'LL FUNDING ONLY THE HIGHEST.
ACHIEVEMENT OF THAT YEAR --
INCLUDING ALSO SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WOULD BEEN
PROVIDED BY THE ACADEMIC SENATE
SO WE HOPE THAT YOU LOOK AT
THOSE AND LASTLY WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOCUSED ON ON
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE --
AS WE'VE REITERATED -- FOR MANY
YEARS STUDENTS NEED MORE THAN
JUST TUITION COSTS COVER THEY
NEED BOOKS TRANSPORTATION AND IN
CALIFORNIA THEY ESPECIALLY NEED
HOUSING COST WE ASK THAT YOU
DON'T TREAT -- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO PRIMARILY SERVE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR DRESS
DIFFERENTLY THAN YOU TREAT UC
AND CSU STUDENTS AND I YOU COVER
THEIR TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHEN MEMBERS ALSO WESTERN BEHALF
THE COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT -- I
WILL ON MY COMMENTS WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE LEAGUE AND WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATE THE ACTION TAKEN HERE
TODAY REGARDING THE FACILITIES
FUNDING WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED DEDICATION OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THAT'S MEMBERS -- TO FUNDING
FINANCIAL AID FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WE ALSO HOPE THAT -- A WITHIN
THAT THE CONTRACT OF YOUR
CONVERSATIONS ARE INCLUDING --
BUDGET MONEY FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TWO CHEESE -- SMALL FIX FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE AGREEMENTS
AND WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JIM MCCARTY AND
QUEEN MEMBERS MANY RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST OF
FIRST AS THE FIFTH FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BELIEVE
THAT OUR STATE LEADERS CAN DO
MORE TO INVEST.
AND COVER THE BASIC NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNICATIVE STUDENTS SO WE
ASKED LEGISLATURE ARE TO TAKE
THE LEAD THERE SPECIAL SPECIALLY
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE NEW DATA
FROM THE HOPE CENTERS REAL
COLLEGE SURVEY SUPPORTS THE
STUDENTS IN A FUNDING FORMULA
AND IT'S EQUITABLE INTENT TO
FOCUS ON THE STUDENT SUCCESS.
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
WE LOOK FORWARD TO MORE DETAILS
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
FROM THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE DATA QUALITY
ISSUES.
AND THE LONG TERM FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY -- AND LAST WE
APPRECIATE THE LA OWES HONEST
ANALYSIS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM REVIEW
THIS PROGRAM AS A STRATEGY AIMED
AT INCREASING COLLEGE AWARENESS.
AND COLLEGE ACCESS UNFORTUNATELY
COLLEGES NOT USING THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVISION WITHIN THE
LAW ARE PRIORITIZING STUDENTS
WITH LESS NEED.
THEREFORE WE ASK LEGISLATURE TO
DEMAND MORE AND BETTER DATA ON
HOW THESE FUNDS ARE BEING USE
LOCALLY IN ORDER TO ELEVATE SOME
OF THESE EQUITY CENTERED BEST
PRACTICES THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT REJECT.
BASICALLY FOR THE YOU KNOW WHAT
TIME IT WILL COME OUT -- EARLIER